tu vois mon écran oui on est parti on va
du coup on est partie des mecs j'avais
lancé le stream est bon on dirait que
des montées c'est un première je te
laisse je te laisse te présenter bonsoir
je vois pas les moins que quand m
j'étais heureuse d'être ici ce soir pas
de kevin et j'espère qu'on va qu'on va
voir un beau spectacle
un crocodile a et b donc tu connais un
petit peu les deux joueuses heureusement
pas trop haut
j'ai pas joué contre eux beaucoup de
partis mais juste bientôt je le connais
comme ça je vais à l'époque et je
prévois d'aller pour moi est ce que tu
as une favorite du coup n'ont jamais été
dans mes favoris dans le sens une
joueuse que tu pense qu'il va gagner à
ses supérieurs
bon je pense que glénat est plus forte
et elle est surtout forte on glisse mais
danielian elle a bien joué elle a déjà
éliminé prêtait une alarme ou non à ce
prix est aussi radicale et na waie donc
elle est d'un coût de 6 donc je pense
que ça va être intéressant
un match tendu ça va un peu suivi les
matchs un petit peu mais pas trop j'ai
dormi un peu rouillée nappes hausse
ténue et daniel vien dollars dans lequel
on est ce qu on a un des deux attend
danilian la gnose qu'augmenter avec
sébastien joie oui et kosteniuk vous
nina je connais je commentais seul nom
donc c'est à dire que quand mathieu
commandes tu ne regardes pas pour faire
ça c'est à dire que tu vois mathieu et
tu te dis oui
marc un match à ne pas commenter alors à
tanger m le chat là on nous dit qu'on a
dit qu'on était en retard que c'est
sponsoring de la sncf
quand tu connais un petit peu la sncf
j'imagine tué des millions d'années en
france
ça fait déjà cinq ans à peu près pareil
donc pas eu le temps de découvrir la
sncf
oui oui mais bon ça va brasser s'est mué
en lituanie le train ou pas ah non à
l'esj lille et hyper lent pour animer
pour faire 1 200 kilomètres comme un
2h30
vous pouvez deux absences
oui pour faire pour faire combien tu dis
enfants de 2 5 et la mettre 200 km donc
c'est la galère mais oui parce qu'on
n'est pas le tgv rien ah non non ça
n'existe pas ça n'existe pas en fait non
dans pour ça que en france les tensions
toualy mal aux portes de paris c'est
deuxième essai 5 km à l'est depuis pas
si longtemps que ça non japp arriver oui
oui ça fait deux anges
ouais ça c'est assez nouveau toi t'es
sur bordeaux donc avec mathieu et ça et
tu ça tu s'il te plaît tu as tu aimes
bien le bon vin bordelais tout ça les
bons plats oui ça me plaît ça ça va tu
as pas envie de retourner vivre en
lituanie vous êtes manque un peu sa
norme une soeur et ma famille mes amis
mon pays mais c'est normal mais j'aime
bien la france aussi fait un peu hein
mais je connais un peu ça avec ma femme
tu vois qu'ils aillent qui vit en france
et qui donc est comme toi tu vas
expatriés elle s'alimente n'arriveront
des fois tu entends des trucs que
l'hiver me manques tu vois fin j'ai
envie de te dire ok il fait moins 35
enfin qu'est ce qui te manque en fait
j'ai du mal à comprendre tu vas
personnellement face avec m
le crois oui ça me manque ma nage ouais
non mais enfin
oui la neige c'est vrai mais tu peux
aller à la montagne talent et perrine à
côté wemmel et mentale
je sais pas ce qu'il y ait donc en avait
mais ça en fait on devait remédier avec
mathieu mais je crois qu'on va avoir du
mal à le faire avait il y avait le gros
projet le gros projet ce qui l'est
l'hiver dernier mais ça n'a pas pu se
faire
et malheureusement j'avais bien essayé
mais bon j'aime
non mais ne t'inquiète pas en fait si tu
as peur du ski alors j'ai une technique
infaillible certus qui avec moi parce
qu'en fait moi je sais je suis quelqu'un
pour les gens qui ont peur du ski qui
est vraiment fantastique parce que j'ai
très peur donc tu te sens beaucoup moins
débile en fait sa pub tu vois moi j'ai
fait du ski peut-être quatre cinq jours
et en fait la seule piste qui me plaît
c'est la piste pour les gamins de deux
ans c'est à dire que là je me sens bien
si tu veux je lui dis ah tiens très
intéressant par contre les pistes pour
adultes tu vois ça va ça m'intéresse pas
trop
ouais je n'aimais pas du goût de jeanne
d écoute j'ai commencé le ski en même
temps que ma femme je vais dire un truc
très simple elle fait des pistes noires
moi j'ai peur sur les pistes bleues mais
je te jure un no fake un no fake wemmel
et ce qui peut être pas pour tout le
monde comme les échecs
enfin les échecs ce n'était pas pour moi
le ski non plus tu vas tu qu'est ce qui
est pour moi que vous l'avez vu que j'ai
pas encore fait mon truc j'ai essayé le
tennis je sens que c'est pas mon truc
non plus je peux être les commentaires
tu vois finalement oui thébaux pour ça
j'avoue ça j'ai trouvé j'ai trouvé un
truc mais maison gloire mais le style en
mai faudra le faire à l'occasion c'est
fantastique
j'aimais bien les seigneurs au moins une
fois de ma vie pour voir ce que c'est
franchement honnêtement je pense que
pour les gens qui arrivent c'est marrant
franchement je sens qu'ils s'amusent
mais
mais moi je n'arrive pas à moi j'ai des
choses les skis tu sais je vais à pied
coiffer un empire bon là tu es là c'est
le moment tu apportes expliquer un peu
en commentaire ce que tu as tu peux dire
que de quoi on parle là c'est un moment
on ne sait pas ce qui se passe tu vas
démente et on est en sueur ça on sue à
grosses gouttes c'est apprendre à
écouter sur le front parce que le match
est en retard on c'est bon on sait pas
et donc là faut qu'on fasse semblant
d'être de bonne humeur en faisant des
petites blagues tu en rigolant un peu
pour que les gens s'en rendent pas
compte tu as donc c'est pas compliqué un
peu tu vas pouvoir te dirai oui bon ok
j'en ai plutôt là pour commenter le truc
goukoye de matthieu aron si bon il ya le
truc qui commence non la suisse est un
peu voilent on peut parler de tout et de
rien donc si tu as envie de te lâcher de
dire un truc tu vas parler lituanie je
sais pas nous raconter une anecdote sur
ta ville natale non je ne sais pas
preneur je tenais je n'aime pas trop
parler
c'est pour ça que ça me fait peur
commenté ce soir web et à bien parler
d'échec pas que ça mathieu qui aiment ça
ils pas les échecs tout le temps d'un
match honda on a on a compris qu'il
aimait parler franchement d'incompris
ouais donc c'est normal du coup bien
qu'ils parlent beaucoup et l'autre par
le point 3 way c'est pour ça c'est pour
ça et c'est pour ça il m'a dit avec
kevin challenger avec avec des montées
ça va bien se passer livre ça a bien
marché vous deux j'ai dit tu parles que
d'échecs que de commentaire j'espère y
m'a dit oui
et donc voilà brimades il a pendant 3h30
je te laisse à très bien se passer
tu vas parler à fond ça va être génial
bien en plus nos fait qu'il est dans le
chat un regarde tu vas tôt crasse 300
alors pourquoi toc race est ce que tu
sais ça il m'a expliqué me rappelle pas
ouais c'était pas forcément c'était pas
marque en coin non non non il ne doit ni
trop froid je pense mais je ne me
rappelle pas ses combles et bryant et
shaquille moment
les ouvertures mais je ne retiens pas s
est ce que tu retiens quand les gens
bougent leurs droits j'étais obligé
j'étais obligé ça là j'étais obligé
c'était méchant mais aujourd'hui ouais
mais c'est faux parce que je je ne me
suis pas aperçu pendant toute la partie
qui est là comme un adversaire l'a fait
un coup ils veulent donc je la perds
vieux je suis rentré dans ma chambre
j'ai commencé à analyser le coordinateur
j'étais très énervé parce que j'ai perdu
et là je ne comprends pas je peux pas
faire la roque et justine et non mais
c'est pas possible mon ordinateur il
plainte en plus j'ai perdu ou gagné tous
nos matches et plus et là je comprends
qu'il y a un problème cette fois
l'ordinateur chênois oui et oui ça m'a
fait beaucoup de mal parti et après
c'était juste trop dur de continuer ses
droits ouais mais tu t'es bien pris
depuis abou je dis tu t'es bien reprises
depuis sur les autres tournois tata part
à jouer là ces derniers temps pas bien
joué mais oui ça va c'est juste ce
tournoi le championnat d'europe féminin
qui dans la cage dollars chaque année
je stresse trop et ça n'aide pas mais
peut-être tu vas arrêter de jouer dans
juste à jeudi je me disent à chaque fois
quand je suis là bas mais après un an
passé et
allez demander c'est un peu masochiste
finalement oui je sais pas j'ai envie de
bien jouer pour une fois mais sam en
janvier donc mais c'est bizarre parce
que pendant l'année
il y avait pour moi mieux que les autres
mais dans tous les cas j'étais enfin 40
30 points là bas
oui tu la récupèrent après tu oui oui
oui mais bon si je je me suis les styles
toujours pas ce tournoi l'échappement
double féminin déjà depuis peut-être
2500 parce que je sais pas j'ai parlé de
100 points je pense qu'en cinq ans là
bas ça c'est beau à 200 points c'est une
forme en fait il a bien dit que chaque
fois j'ai trente quarante points donc
c'est incroyable mais c'est fou oh et
puis ça arrive on a tous des toits qu'on
a du mal à jouer après c'est un peu
psychologique un tat pts est un montage
armand oui c'est sûr de sa bande de
comprendre mais maintenant je suis juste
un piccolo est ce que tu as déjà un
petit peu bosser avec travailler avec
avec des coachs mental ou pas moi même
parce que tu es tu étais combien
mondiale la démente actuellement tu es
dans le top 30 ou honnêtement je n'aime
pas le garder c'est que avant le
shampooing d'europe j'étais numéro 19
mais après quand j'ai perdu 30 moi je
n'ai aucune vis de mes jeux que tu es ce
que tu veux que je te dise on va
regarder ça et c'était démonter cornet
tout démonter d'olite et du coup mais je
sais pas j'étais dans les dépôts nets et
là j'ai modifié en commun n'ont donc ça
l'intégralité de nantes et de l'it et
korn est maintenant t'es même pas
connaître d'olite était de l'it et
cornette
oui bon mode précis alors tu es 24 44
ouais t'es 23,81 rapide
ouais 22 79 ans glisse et et 31e
mondiale
ok c'est pas mal ouais franchement
évoqué mais je vois valentina lna ouais
ça va commencer ça va commencer tu es
quelque part ouais non mais c'est bien
31e mondial n'empêche sans rigoler ça va
oui faire un peu mieux tes 20e
européenne était 2e lituanienne carrière
une fille qui est député j'imagine ans
et les députés allaient quoi aller on ne
sait pas d ptc c'est une femme politique
ah oui oui travail dans le comblement
des allées par les parlementaires du
coup oui alors attends c'est pas encore
parti c'était d'autres partis que
regarder avant en fait je fais attention
de voir quand ça démarre en temps ça je
vais mettre comme ça et je vais s'est
passé ça ici situe à cause de notre
petit problème technique d'affichage du
coup on a une petite difficulté pour un
et le visage des joueurs et les échecs
et en même temps on regardera
l'échiquier de façon le visage non on
s'en fiche un peu non oui mais le plus
important du michigan a donc là ça pas
encore tout à fait démarrer puisque le
match est pas parti et le tchad je le
gardais là et vanina qui joue avec nous
avons trop de chance il donc du coup il
ya toi qui joues un pro de chez slick il
ya vanina oui mais la dernière elle
pouvait pas en fait à chaque fois tu
écrivais a été très heureuse de jouer
mais elle pouvait jamais en fait
d'accord oui dames 1 non mais l'année
prochaine on gagne en plus l'année
prochaine il se peut qu'on est un
renfort de très gros points on en
négociations avec un très gros renforts
mais je peux pas en dire plus mais je
peux te dire que c'est du top 10 mondial
bah oui alors presque top 10 mondial
masculin féminin je garde le suspense
peut-être les deux mais peut-être les
deux en plus ce serait encore mieux
ouais il serait génial on prend on fait
on fait faire une opération à vlad et on
prend vlad tu sais qu'on a un culte de
vlad si c'est votre vérité hawaïen tout
le monde un culte pour l'admets mais
nous plus particulièrement que tu
connais d'ailleurs bad pour
personnellement il faut remédier à ça il
va falloir remédier à ça non mais v'là
de la vague qui était qui était
d'ailleurs femmes on parle un peu tu as
des échecs féminin entre guillemets qui
était au
au tournoi des candidates a réagi la n
est qu il a aidé katia sens sans trop de
succès d'ailleurs
ce geste vise tout le monde j'ai vu
qu'elle n'a pas très bien joué il a dit
que karachi qui n'a été vraiment très
impressionnante
bah oui son résultat c'est vraiment
impressionnant
oui moments comme ça ouais non mais
c'est il a dit qu'il avait les nerfs
d'acier de quoi elle avait les nerfs
d'acier bon alors ce match est ce que
mais là et aurait donc là ce soir là
quand même
on est quand même pour valentina nantis
peut on jouer avec elle quand même tu as
donc du coup puis les gens la
connaissent tu as dans le chat ils sont
là mais oui allez on va supporter qu'est
ce que ces partis mais moi je jouais je
vois pas le match fin tu vois je vois
valentina tu vois vanina 1989
je lave ou en ligne mais mes deux
matches non il n'est pas parti en outre
hall dans le tchat
ayé sur le compteur
royer sur le compteur c'est parti mais
les partis sont pas partis c'est pas
possible
suivre ok je suis vanille darmon est
sûre si ça y est c'est parti c'est un
bug donc à tant de 4,6 cavalière trois
des cinq peut prendre des prises des 4
cavaliers à 6tu marc est un dq veut dire
quelque chose tu me stoppe il faut avec
5 6 3 est-ce que déjà tu joues cette
ouverture là les avoir en échange de la
française démente et oui vous des fois
avec les blancs mais la magie je viens
de monter mon mieux comme ça donc je ne
prenais pas un très très bien donc du
coup en gros la position c'est assez
égale lane en basset symétrique
oui mais j'ai pas est toujours plaisant
agréable pour les blancs ou noirs
viennent pas trop d'activités - est-ce
que tu joues en deuxième quoi et donc là
tu défends tu ferais quoi avec le pour
le pion 17 pensent qu on le défend j'en
fais du tour bénite ou ou cavaliers b6
ou juste tu penses on peut ignorer une
truc je sais pas moi faire ces 5 ou
encore répété j'aime pas lb si ce soir
c'est bête tu veux faire des six accusés
de faire ces 5
ouais tu l'as pas casser 6 ouais mais
qu'est ce qu'un temps mais qu'est ce que
tu vas faire avec
est ce que je peux faire flamber 5 pour
essayer de venir dessus des foetus ou c5
quand même à de bons rails et le plan
sésame bien on commence bien
non mais j'ai laissé 4 en quoi ça fait 4
encore bon avoir écouté a continué toute
façon on va voir ce qu'elle a fait
d'ailleurs ma question c'est la première
phrase c'est pas c'est quoi la cadence
et 5,5 plus un simple cinq plus un
adepte et après les trois plus en éolien
et l'année prochaine on va essayer de
réessayer d'un petit peu influencé pour
que tu puisses le jouer quoi on va voir
où on va on espère avec mathieu on
espérait que tu sois sélectionné on
était très chaud franchement non
franchement ça va ça le ferait donc à la
fée tourbe et huit essais si ce n'est
que le 5 mai c'est peut-être un peu
mieux pour les banques est peut-être un
jour on me fout en f4 ont fait remarquer
le fraph ou des six noms comme il ya
trois ou quatre mois je dois faire le
blanc après ça reste un peu baveux faire
prêt à faire genre food et 6
les fous dit si tu fais cavaliers 3way
leur tour eu 8 chez pie x f4 bon ok mais
peut-être fou price trois coups donc
attend ça veut dire que ça c'est une
c'est peut-être une option du coup pour
pour les membres ok tu peut-être
commencer en protestant que ça marche
pas ouais c'est pas mal c'est pas mal ça
a l'air plus agréable pour les blancs tu
t'assois faire un truc comme dams et 7
pour des crues ou quoi mais c'est plus
agréable voir ce qui s'est passé il ya
vait cavaliers 5 tours 8 tf carte assez
bien ça fait quatre ans qu'elle ménage
et gateway même pas des pros mais
maintenant
manon est maintenant tous et si tu fais
h6 elle te fait g4 et on fout peut pas
les anges et si ça ok mais risque parce
qu as tu fait genre d eux il ya qu il ya
des échecs intermédiare un truc mais
c'est quand même il a jugé qu à 13,5
oui c'est ça mais il se passe quoi sur
g4 et je pense que l'un en perdent
au caire quelque chose pas possible
on va voir mais la première vue à la fée
dames c'est le ya peut-être un truc avec
un échec et d'un match 4 quelque chose
comme ça d'accord ouais mais il faut
s'interroger d'où à damas cap parce que
la cour a down the way aimerait
peut-être quelque chose
ok mais là tu peux juste bouger le roi
et tu continues à menacer g4 f5 et tu me
l'as vous prend 1,7 oued un peu le pas
la mort ça pas trop quoi faire avec ce
faux soit on change
ouais il ya et c'était super bien joué
le f4 de vanina quoi oui je sens qu'il
est coopté comme ça à temps mais avec
les noirs est ce qu'on peut pas jouer je
rage 6 g4 est fou prend ouais c'est
possible ici mais après tu feras d'un
match cap d'un prof mais beaucoup avec
les mains
brièvement il ne faut pas se précipiter
est ce qu'on peut faire un croix comme
les coûts inutiles loyers du tout quand
j ai pris quatre
ouais ouais bouger le fouet puis ont
gardé chez 4,5 pour la suite bon à la
partie du coup elle a fait bouger 6 à
elle veut faire la même fosse 5
elle songe à coeur de le prendre ouais
donc et qui a rallié f3 plus ou moins
tempo vous prend dame prend cavalia
fuite food et 2 à 5 tours eux
elle va miner leur tour un tapis kf5 f6
non ouais comme ça pareil genre très
bien pour les blancs ça franchement mais
bon après j'ai envie de te dire il faut
pas te faut pas tuer là pour vendre la
peau de l'ours avant de l'avoir tué faut
pas se précipiter dans l'analyse dans le
sens où pendant tout ce tournoi à chaque
fois que j'ai vu les parties d'elina
elle était tout le temps sur le fil du
rasoir
tu vois à tenir mon justesse et à chaque
fois il se sauvaient tu vois
ouais elle s'accroche pas c'est son
style quoi parce que là en réalité
ok elle est un peu comme ça très souvent
elle est bourrée de position mais le
surf c'est pas facile
d'abord parce qu'elle s'accroche ouais
ils sont plein et tu vas y tu l'a jamais
battu en partie longue balle en sinon je
pense que je l'aï jamais jouée en partie
donc on nage de fait les rapides je leur
ai joué l'année dernière au champion du
monde à ryad
on a fait une yole et je croyais perdu
le deuxième
tu t'es le blessé un infini le plus
rapide et c'est qui la joueuse la plus
forte que t'es battue je dis bien joué
un jeu dit pas joueur en général dans
les joueuses
bref les chiens mais tu as déjà battu
une meuf qui était une fille c'était top
10 mondial
pas sûr j'ai battu mon chien il ya dix
ans mais n'était pas encore je me lâche
pas bon ménage avec une fille qui a été
championne du monde ammann c'est toi
c'est ton mari qui répond guy chambily
thb c'est vrai est oubliée
tu vois il se rappelle mieux ils
étudient j'ai un nouvel moon avoir
pourtant pour le bio la demande marie
pour l'air
on est parti pour les verts qui donc tu
n'es pas grand maître de mémoire c'est
génial du coup tu dois galères et non
mais après ce qu'on apprend très vite
les gamins la partie et je mémorise
c'est mieux mais ça je ne sais ça nous
garde ça ne sauvegarde pas trop
longtemps dans la tête c'est ça le
problème
elle était une bonne mémoire à court
terme et à une mauvaise mémoire à long
terme
en tout cas je parle bien français merci
ça c'est cool
du coup tours 4 bon mais son placement
en soins quatre voitures gardent la
pendule aussi deux minutes deux minutes
5 contre 10 9 secondes
mêlant valentina elle est tellement
favorite de ce match pour moi en tout
cas mieux quoi aux échecs juste oui oui
mais juste récemment je trouve qu'elle
joue un peu moins bien qu'avant je sais
pas c'est juste un périodes comme ça où
j'ai l'impression qu'elle est à moins
d'énergie comment et son style pour son
style elle a besoin d'avoir beaucoup
d'énergie parce que je très active elle
veut sacrifier tout le temps quelque
chose donc si t'as pas d'énergie c'est
très dur de jouer comme ça ouais il
sacrifie tout le temps ouais elle
cherche les coupes les cascio un tout
temps même si la position est
sans elle peut compliquer les choses
ouais elle jouait en rapide et
ambitieuse je me rappelle là on est en
ayant revu en se pliant le speech est
c'était pareil mais tu te rappelles
quand on joue en pro de chasse lions
après toi tu jouais souvent avec elle du
coup mais franchement tu regardais les
parties albite c'est tout le monde
c'était impressionnant attend les a pas
cavaler prendre b4 et surtour b3 qui
sait si ce qu'elle veut faire elle veut
prendre prendre et gagner je pensais
qu'elle prendrait des 8es qu'elle
gagnerait la finale oui oui on n'a pas
changé parce que du coup en fait
cavalier conte de fou avec un jeu sur
deux axes étaient calmes aux avantages
parce que elle a fait les royals ont la
trouille maintien ouais elle aurait pu
choper le pion et là le truc c'est que
elle repère le pion elle va récupérer g7
mais pas assez il faut prendre
maintenant regarder ces nuls
intéressants
ok mais ça c'est du non mais elle aurait
dû et elle aurait dû échanger
elle aurait dû échanger les tours en b 8
et gagner avec l'option a clairement et
gunino valentina qui l'avait battue qui
avait battu vlad à gibraltar
pour nous c'est un exploit a su assez
mais alors je peux raconter une anecdote
extraordinaire parce que en fait je
connais la partie parce que c'est mon
répertoire et du coup j'ai dit à vlad
eux quatre ces six c4 et on parle un peu
de ça tu vas 7/4 au calme avec ses 4 ans
et gia et de l'anneau dit oui mais les
noirs peuvent égaliser glee c'est pas
mal ce c'est une surprise mais si tu
connais bien ça égalise unis oui
notamment tu es perdu une partie contre
valentina à gibraltar et la vlad me
répond un truc extraordinaire
il me dit oui c'est vrai mais ça ne
compte pas parce que c'était la partie
du matin non mais c'est génial on fait
ça que tu as perdu une partie on te cite
la partie qui a perdu mais ils te
répondent mais ça ne compte pas quoi
enfin le genre c est gentil mais
vraiment très confiant mais j'en sais
ces pays répartis en fait c'est une
partie du matin donc du coup en fait je
n'ai pas perdu quoi je n'ai pas vraiment
pas au nom aujourd'hui le genre qui est
juste des tests de feu le manteau rose
c'est pas possible
et toi du coup à moi je n'aime pas mais
bon si je perds je n'étais pas que ça ne
compte pas attendons la partie contre m
tout le monde n'aime pas la jouer le
matin mais il faut le pauvre mais s'il
faut il faut n'en voie de communiqué en
usi dans le chatt locative lane ne perd
jamais même quand il perd mais c'est
tout à fait ça même en ayant perdu il
n'avait pas perdu en fait ouais écoute
valentina qui a joué peut-être un petit
peu vite non ah oui elle avait beaucoup
plus de temps non pas trop les riches et
donc c'est une semi tarrach s'appelle ce
matin je ne suis pas prêt ce semi tu vas
y rajoute semi devant les noms des fois
j'ai jamais compris ne me pose pas les
noms mais t'inquiète pas moi non plus du
coup tu peux être très confiante quoi tu
peux envoyer tu peux tu peux me renvoyer
la balle mais juge agnès que tu as ta
l'état d'état rachat des semis tard à
faire un tueur pourquoi semi tu as faim
d'où vient ce mot est ce que quelqu'un
le sait dans le chat parce qu'on a une
armée de gens qui peuvent nous répondre
et parce que tu auras va tout répondre
tant crisis is et tu penses bon alors du
coup cette position c'est moi j'aime
bien le genre de truc avec les noirs
personnellement parce que je me dis
qu'un jour je vais dépenser 4 et je vis
le pion de l'option isolé ouais bmo par
et moi j'aime pas trop jouer avec
non mais quand je vous contrôlez je
trouve que c'est pas facile non plus
donc c'est compliqué pour les du coup tu
vas être très intéressé par le bar la
série vidéo qu'on va sortir avec matt va
faire très intéressé genre je parle que
tu vois pas ça j'en peux plus je n'en
peux plus je n'en peux plus lier va
revenir chez moi à partir du 10 juillet
on va on va continuer à filmer ça mais
honnêtement quand j'ai fait parce qu'ils
me donnent des fichiers tuam envoie des
fichiers pour faire la vidéo il me dit
tiens je t'envoie ça regarde apprend et
tu me pose les questions pendant la
vidéo mais j'imagine tu vois c'est un
peu comme quand toi tu apprends les
ouvertures
genre tu as l'impression que tu en a
plein qui t'arrive dans le cerveau tu as
d'information est en fait tu te
rappelles de plus rien après mais genre
c'est assez assez difficile quoi voilà
du coup y'a plus de pure isolé alors
c'est quoi cette position je me dis
toujours que si tu as le pion aux 5 et
que lecavalier arrive pas en d6 que ça
va pour les noirs tuque envoyé n'allume
pas oui qui n'arrive pas ici et en plus
je vois pas où mettre le faux de khaznah
à la fondeuse ça ça et ça non
on double ou pas oui je trouve que pour
l'invention est plus facile à jouer non
ouais ouais ouais non plus facile c'est
sûr mais après peut-être que les blancs
ils peuvent liquider lé tour et faire un
nul
oui oui
non c'est faux et 4 il n'y a pas une
histoire de fou c est un bon copain
capital faisait 5 b 4 oui mais peut-être
tu reviens en recettes
oui après et après tu fais à 5 ça marche
pas oui ça marche on va en gagner sur un
train mais on va tout changer
ouais après on peut se le garder sous le
coude quoi et là j'ai foncé simple à la
je faisais c'est un coin est-ce que
helena web et 4 ses responsables comme
coupé 4 h 15 elle fait encore son 1
on peut et c'est peut-être de faire du
four n'ont pas joué c'est de partir par
là bas mais est ce que tu veux faire
plusieurs fois à 6 pour aller pour aller
jaillir la bave atteint futur assez ça
c'est mieux ça mais non elle domine un
peu ouais je trouve que les pièces blanc
ne sommes pas très bien placé par un peu
cow boys bref trois avec une bonne chose
le faux sourds des deux os non plus à
ramener 4 mais peut-être numéro un se
fout je pense aussi parce que des
parents chaussures mais peut-être la
fois 4 surtout un machin des peut-être x
4 x 4 et bouffe c'est vite vu ses 8
genre tu as un truc comme ça quant à
l'échiquier qui change un peu de
couleurs c'est qu'on analyse pour battre
notre père et l'a peut-être la tour pas
facilement à je vais peut-être tour des
3 1 ont faussé de ses patrons
peut-être c'est un os 6 1 6 4 après ok
peut-être tombe mais mes tours bien
c'est quand même moche mais mon tour
viendra voir les 7,3 mais tour à tour
s'inquiéter de way annoncé jean on
retourne sur le direct elle a fait
fourrer fuite n'a pas fait x 4 il faut à
4 c'était tentant quand même un ouais
alors je peux à lui mais tu vois là oh
regarde je vais allumer pour que toi
aussi tu l'aies on a le petit module
qu'on peut
ça a l'air bien de temps en temps ok
donc on peut on peut généralement je
n'allume pas pour que tu rends puisse
commenter tranquillement le sens
ensemble ce que sinon ça influence et du
fait que leurs gardes et après tu peux
plus tu peux plus rien à voir mais ça
permet tu vois de se mettre à certains
moments et dans une petite indication de
l'ordinateur donc c'est pour que tu que
tu que tu vois où c'est comme ça tu tu
peux en profiter aussi quand je l'allumé
tu vois il aime bien x 4 alors d'içi y
donnent ils donnent moins là oui bah
tour des 3 tu vas leur dis propose tour
des trois camps et des tours c'est en
fait le redis il propose à peu près ce
qu'on analyse avec toi wintour des trois
océans et on a oublié derrière regarde
culture h4 est en prise aussi à wil à l
abri le cordonnier way
ah non là ça va ça sent mauvais pour
pourrir là franchement tu vas le sur le
scénario des deux premières parties
tu vois ça je pense que ça peut finir en
mode france croatie tu vois tu vas te
calmes at je parle ouais coupe du monde
de football battue tu te rappelles alors
on leur a mis combien leurs amis on leur
a mis trois ou quatre ans déjà je me
rappelles tu en auras tellement mis deux
buts que je me rappelle même plus qu'on
leur ait atteint kevin un an
c'est bon iver qu'est un enfermement de
quelque chose oui j'ai pensé qu'il y ait
approuvé s'armer jusqu'aux vaut mieux
prendre en compte ou non mais ok là
franchement sur les deux premières
parties pour le moment au théron
le match vient de commencer mais pour le
moment quand même grosse domination de
valentina qui pousse de partout et en
plus valentina j'ai remarqué dans les
premiers matches elle a besoin de
rentrer dans le match donc si elle
rentre bien ça va être infernale pour
pour elin à elle joue encore mieux avec
la confiance elle est juste une
monstrueuse incroyable trapel en pro de
chez ces dames on reparle de vanina mais
elle avait failli battre et el fallah
effet nul finalement non mais après
d'intenses pressions on y meurt c'est
jamais facile de me rencontrer
elle a un très beau chat en plus très
heureux du choix
par le son de son chat du coup h5 à le
faire quoi j'ai 5 h 4 j'imagine que oui
elle a un point de plus et pour les
pousser allez salut faire un pion pas
s'éloigner en plus ils plongez-y
bougeoirs du cavaliere quatre échecs
à bientôt le même âge de ghb ah oui
c'est vrai info des neuf et une peau
d'un vrai tu t'en prends deux options et
ça a l'air bien seulement après on aura
aussi à 5
bon bah on va attaquer des deux côtés
quoi ça est beau le foot est bien placé
non là c'est ça l'art d'être fantastique
pour pour pour les noirs si elle ratisse
un parc en ciel le rates tu vois
peut-être psychologiquement ça peut ça
peut lui mettre un petit coup parce que
ça fera deux positions devant danger
mais parfois il faut dire je suis pas
convaincu parce que le roi est ce qu'il
n'a pas mieux son objet de blocs
impulsion et achetons pourquoi une
invasion elle n'a pas joué son football
ouais c'est sûr qu'avec la toile on y
apprend être 4 il faut dire non non on a
on a parlé de ça mais à fourcade
oui on attend le fouet dans les délais
mais là pas trop ce qu'il a fait voter
sur fond 3h 4
tours h3 ouais il n'ya pas fou et 7
passes katura je suis même âge est ce un
petit ouais bon ça paraît encore chaud
hein on va voir on va voir si ça se
passe comme ça j'ai pris quatre la fée
g6 ok petit lait tout racheter entourage
t'inquiète pas ah oui et le coût est
encore non mais là encore il faut pour
un médium et attends je me demande si
elle peut maintenant qui est moins bien
j'exagère mais je me suis elle continue
elle peut même se retrouver mal parce
que ces pièces elles manquaient ya le
pion aux quais le curage 4 est quand
même faible et mais juste les pièces
noires peuvent être des routes d
organiser c'est julien gonnet tu peux
prendre peut-être fou prend prises qui
est ici six pales pion à 7 qui reste en
l'air fou g5
ouais ça peut ça peut carrément tourné
quel est le plus maintenant hélas
quel est le matériel oui et elles
souffrent ponant ouais encore de temps
mais bon et il inhale a fait ça tout le
tournoi elle est tout en bas l'otan
quand elle est mal autant elle se bat
bien joué d'accord mais elle a pris sur
des simples oui il ya plus d'internet
pour pour vanina qui se déconnectent bon
elle a de nouveau internet mais mais
elle joue d'un hôtel en fait ce qu'elle
avait oublié qu'il y avait une finale
en quoi donc elle n'est pas chez elle et
ouais non mais elle va se prendre le
camion ses six salles va être mal elle
va être mal carniel franc ça tu vois ça
ça m'étonne c'est ici si ça ne paraît
que ça paraissait logique non mais
peut-être et la peur oui
non je sais pas ok mais cavani h3 juste
avec la case me paraît étrange moquette
ou g5 ça c'est logique
bon elle va à la main assez loin ce
destin qui elle va perdre quoi elle
menace pas de légende et 5 pour la mort
aux côtés de pourquoi pas pris la
plupart viennent et qu'on fait le ménage
tour des cinq anneaux est pour notre
série
je vais je ne les lis retour des saints
tôt et sur 17
je pense qu'elle veut un truc c'est
genre cavaliers des quatre le retour f3
je te bloque ton fou et après je joue
sur le sur l'autre aile non mais là il
est juste très bien là en fait elle va
t'on f3 il ya qu'à valider cinq ou six
qui plus rodés protège le pion j'adore
les six hockey sur assist lui faire
payer huit cavaliers des sept épreuves
et 6 ok quoi 2 arrive au caire apprend
son bras droit ok mais elle peut jouer
pour tour des huit cavaliers ou 7 au g8
machin etc les matelas bah voilà ça
passe à part dans le n'importe quoi là
on est quatre là ouais c'est mort f4 tu
as raison f4 c'est fini
l4 c'est fini incroyable incroyable au
le craquage le craquage total ah ouais
en plus il y avait comme aller déclare
je pense aussi non à la fin oui avec
doigté catete tourcoing f2 je crois à
l'époque non mais incroyable parce que
c'est stéphane girel elle a perdu entre
guillemets bêtement dans le sens où h4
c'était vraiment pas nécessaire
joe dassin que j'ai acheté mon chapeau
mais je pense qu'elle a oublié tout
rouge 3 parce que après j'ai pas cher de
la vraie vie si jeune homme qu'elle a
compris qu'il ya un problème
bon ça a réussi à le blesser
ouais mais bon vin tu vois ça arrive ça
arrive mais ça fait déjà deux parties et
il récemment il reste du temps parce que
regarde il reste une heure 55 + 1 et
puis à prendre encore une heure de 2,3
plus sain et encore une demi-heure de
bullet dont canal temps de revenir mais
mais tu sais c'est les occasions ratées
tiens quand tu rates les zones de gagner
le match il faut pas rater comme ça
ouais ses occasions c'est en fait de
quoi ça en fait des au lieu de zéro
elles aient mené d'un point et donc là
c'est une c'est quoi c'est une genre
d'ouest indienne ouais je joue pas du
tout ça je sais pas si toi tu dis je
savais quand même passé par ailleurs
c'est une langue qui il ya un petit peu
ruiz est ce que j'ai envie de dire avec
les plus indécis c'est aussi la méthode
ruiz bon du coup des cinq sages aime
bien les bleus encore perso j'ai pas dis
ce que tu en penses
mais le fou bien faire mambé cette
position ferme et les cavaliers
ouais après comme je n'y suis pas je
suis pas spécialiste mais en double je
pense pour nous c'est mieux que les
verts pour se terminer au plus tôt
possible d'analyser le plus tôt ça se
termine le mieux c'est et là je prends
une kora lié à un cap ou dégâts et parra
elle fouille pas mal placée en d4
après un coup encore les messins qui
peuvent arriver méthodes peuvent se
jouait mais que cinq noms ouais où tu as
peur de te prendre juste la marée pion à
voir mais ça va être la partie peut-être
parce qu'elle a pris 1,5 après tu peux
faire roi chant premier f1 quoi que tu
as peut-être envie de faire f 4 et 2 est
invité deux fois à venir en d4
ouais enfin un jeu auquel ils
m'encouragent et quatre mois donc si tu
peux aussi faire f4 un jour et surtout
des cas de faire rage deux états mettant
bout à bout les blancs bah je vous dis
que le fou en dix-sept films c'est pas
c'est pas le meilleur foot bessette de
l'histoire non on les appelle et gérard
depardieu sur cette chaîne est souvent
pourquoi la grippe
je pas parce qu'ils mangent des trucs
sur la diagonale tu as aidé gérard
depardieu et mais ça c'est un gérard
depardieu triste tu vois c'est vrai va
juste faire b34 à la rigueur non saturés
la gg il est mal quoi gérard depardieu
national auquel auquel va prendre
prendre et prendre des 5 c'est ça est ce
qu'elle peut prince au dessin que je
fous ces villages où p 5
vous éviterez pas et là j'ai
l'impression qu'avec le fou au catch a
qu'à voir une pièce supplémentaire en
attaque pour les blancs des genres et
tous ses mythes ci revient jamais
défendre si tu fais 5 tu laisses la case
de six terrains
bon elle va essayer d'attaquer le plus
en ce secteur
j'imagine mais bon je peux simplement je
me fous des 3 est un jeu où il faut fou
tour des cabinets
oui tu feras fou des 3 es tu pourras
doublé sur la colonne de et attaquer ici
oui du coup avec les blancs époux prend
ferait pas fou des trois heures avec les
blancs toute façon on a besoin de la
prendre cette colonne nan tu peux aussi
faire dame ces deux peut-être pour taper
là c'est pas bête
on va jouer ici du coup peut-être après
on peut essayer de faire un truc comme
ça
pour madame devant wii epic 7 passes
oui en confort des trois forêts france
paraît pas bête non tu défendes fiancée
quatre façons c'est ce que tu voulais
faire tu prépares un peu la colonne euh
ouais c'est ce qu'elle a fait
maintenant je pense que c'est vraiment
bien pour pour les blancs tu vois
franchement ce truc a faits sur ses
quatre ça paraît pas pas fou quoi ça
fait pas trop peur non ok mais elle veut
prises les deux tours b 2 ouais c'est le
défaut de défier deux peut-être ça
laisse la dame noire de sortir les
pcistes je sais pas si c'est abraham
maintenant tous les corps les nord ils
ont eu plus moi je pense oui elle est de
nouveau déconnecté eh bien non mais si
elle est toute en déconnecté ça va être
très tendu en ce qu'elle s'est
reconnecté elle se déconnecte admis en
moins de temps qu'il fait tours 2 1 et
aura deux pour un péché mais prend ses
canettes pour but de est un peu ton
jouet torrent et on menace sera
peut-être dans certains monde jean
reprise prise prise prises et tours 8
suivant oui mais parfois tu sûr que ça
marche je pense qu'une union
c'est pas terrible de prendre soin des
symptômes déjà pas mal bah ça veut dire
par contre que si tu fais le retour b6
soit genre une grande comme ça en
admettant tu vois c'est un peu con con
mais c'est pour montrer non mais là où
il avait couru en théorie
moi j'ai pas réussi à bien rentrer
ok finalement elle repart naturelle elle
prend elle prend le plan qu'on avait de
base de manioc de repartir ans et 8 à
essoyes c'est pas bête elle veut fou g4
est situé est tombé 2 mais peut-être ça
marche encore mieux de cette position
parce que notre fou il l'est plus objet
2 et l'effort de 3 donc il ya le dos et
ball a condamné notre droit bon alors du
coup des fausses couches et 4 allait
obliger plus ou moins dans le sont pas
sont elles pas une science est donc d4
bon sens mais ne rien manquer comment on
fait avec les blancs parce que surtout
un yakuza 4
oui c'est ça mais peut-être est-ce qu'on
joue f3 ici au caire 1 3 ok tu préfères
f3 puis tour euh oui c'est ça parce que
je vaux prendre trop de coups confiant
mais du coup je pense que c'est bien
joué de la papa bien jouer de savoir
faire à trois dans le sens où où tu
permettait tout recettes soit j'aurais
préféré f3 direct pour faire toi ok mais
non elle peut peut-être joué pour prise
prisé damas quatre noms mais là si les
noms prend époux g4 ok admettons les
noirs prennent et fou j'ai 4 3 3 et
nancy 3 à non je peux pas prendre part
au 7 mai du club des quatre
ouais mais tu peux tu aimerais mesdames
des quatre tours e breizh tour quatre
dames ces trois mots on va voir comment
ça s'est développé tout reprendre tout
reprend fou j'ai carré coûte c'est la
partie d'accord mais là j'aime si un
jeune homme de coeur d'un bep site est
possible pour les
est mort parce que la menace pas grand
chose pour l'instant jamais peut-être on
pourra faire damas un après essayez de
menacer un flou h3 d'un machin mais est
ce que ça marche
non pas pour avoir le pion à 5 quoi ok
je suis un mail à l'aps est ta main
c'est pas idiot genre peut-être h5 elle
te prends et tu fais damart oui et là tu
veux ça sera vraiment fois je trois
prises h3 et mais maintenant un rat elle
a joué 1 5
et si je joue d'un menu simple comme ça
qu'on va l'intérêt profond d'adoption à
5 fait ce que tu joues si la dame elle
prend là elle pourra revenir ici
exactement c'était mon idée c'est de ton
pu le faire d'un marcel je sais pas ok
peut-être elle veut faire tourbe et 8 en
fait c'est ça les rend et rentre en b2c
ça qu'elle veut faire mais est ce que ça
ne fait peur qu'ils ont fait dans
l'enceinte d'un vent et on pose les
pions en est le maître la torah de genre
tu vas faire damas cinq tours b 8 dames
1 tourbes et deux à quatre tours à 2 à 5
ouais elle est tellement et j'avoue que
m c'est que la torah des vraiment bien
placé et pièces mois en très actif à
mais tu sais quoi ah non ça marche pas
je voulais faire tout reprend m 2 et x
jeu 3 mai ok on va remettre la partie la
remontée un hammam en un prétoire ben
oui ton père tu as comme info
mais elle peut faire tomber de hockey 12
infos prend 1,4 mais non il faut croire
1,4 et mais elle doit cas tu es tombé de
haut c'est parce que tour b2c possible
d'apprendre n'est pas jouable est un nom
elle a pris 1 à 4 à 2 peut-être est-ce
que je peux maintenant c'est bête parce
que dans machete sais pas s'il faut
prend 1,4 c'était sympa mais ça que
j'aime bien vous diriez vous qu'il y
avait peut-être revenir faudra peut-être
tour f4 du coup ça c'est toi ok mais
faut qu'elle joue pour gagner la
valentine
ok nul n a pas pris de risques mais
ouais partie vraiment c'était peut-être
la meilleure partie dans le contenu
celle là et en ferons nous dit que tu as
magnus en train de battre encore il est
en train d en train de gagner contre
contrat nand incroyable ans magnus ouais
enfin elle s'invente pas il s'arrête pas
il est un stockage
donc qu'est-ce qu'on a là on a un genre
de voeux trois poisons
si tu as lu le bouquin d'axel spis tu
connais axel smith oui je la joue un
tonneau des danaïdes
donc ils te recommande de jouer des
quatre cavaliers f3 et de trois autres
importe quoi et un livre
je suis les pales et donc en fait c'est
un peu ça qu'elle est en train de faire
avec les blancs mais l'inconvénient
c'est que le fou c'est un reste bloquée
c'est un peu pénible 80 mais sûrement
après moi j'aime bien les noirs une
nouvelle fois j'ai l'impression toutes
les ouvertures
j'aime bien valentina mais non mais non
en fait j'ai l'impression que tu as à
tes pions pendant mai
ouais ok tu vas faire v3 four b2 mais
j'ai l'impression qu'avec les ventes a
vraiment rien obtenu quoi cavaliers
c'est ici je me mets à s'équiper 4,2
mètres la tour ans et 8 je préfère
fougue et 8 d'amd si tu vois pas je
pense que la mort après c'est peut-être
une question de style aussi c'est pas
parce qu'on a un style de jeu qui
ressemble plus aux hostile de ce que
elina souvent tu vois qu'elle a des
positions où aller où elle a pas trop
d'espacé un peu rampant et elle joue
très bien donc c'est que c'est que ça va
lui convenir et qu'elle les joues bien
injuste donc elle a fait cavalier seul
gueye 17 pourquoi plutôt car il y est
accueilli 6,6 peut-être bon écoute
donc les tuons pendant qu'est ce qu'on
veut faire on veut échanger des pièces
avec les blancs mais est ce qu'on peut
faire ça d'après ce qu'on peut on ne
s'est pas tu vas mais les gens tu veux
quoi et 48 hours et mitsubishi 8
bah oui pourquoi pas
et donc avec les blancs qu'est ce que tu
peux mais rapidement je suis un pauvre
on joue ses positions des trois faux pas
de son vous pour rien dans mon
développement
tu peux faire comme ça aussi fou du roi
on retient les tours c'est un poète 5
elle menace déjà qu'est ce qu'une
managem maintenant trianon qui ont des
seins qui est protégé sans faute et on
prend avec la dent oui je comprend pas
trop ce mot prayssas et thématiques dans
ces structures se faire flouer 5 mais
bon tu as et mais en fait juste
normalement c'est que tu au calme une
fois h3 bon genre me dire pourquoi pas
ça face à ces thématiques de ce
déplacement de fou mais juste
l'impression que c'est un peu prématuré
dans le sens où tu as beaucoup de pièces
qui ont développé encore domaine des
cartes froid et froid ça peut être
candidat ici ça ne l'a pas fait mais
c'était envisageable
non mais elle veut faire près du camp se
faire juste tour 8es j'aurai mon
ordinateur je souhaite mettre la
puissance entre ta sont des quatre elle
aura tout le temps je vois pas trop
comment les bras ils peuvent empêcher
cette idée la tâche 5 carrier g4 aussi
non dans les trucs qui peuvent un jour
une tête dure parce que tu as qui ont
des quatre ans prises mais a eu aucun
attention hockey est là je dois me
trouver 3 auquel la pagaille tu as envie
de faire salon maintenant avec la dame
russe est en plus
quand peut-être mais mandat me en échec
à la fin nous regardons ce qui fait ça
non mais j'ai des cages union et tu peux
même pas faire tourcoing gafou proche de
je pense à elle dames auquel peut-être
signerait mais peut-être qu'à tours f4
et j'ai cinq mais j'ai cinq âgés 5,20 m
ahmed avait cinq si on prend un malin
profite donc à voir mais bon ces
minerais le fait pas j'ai pas pour les
ont pas afin qu'elle joue pas d'accord
parce que c'est un coup c'est
complètement son style d'entraîneur je
mets juste une petite évaluation de leur
dis juste pour voir parce que tu vois
quand il ya un coup comme ça qui nous
tente pour voir un peu ce que les
joueuses ont pu voir ce qu'on a pu rater
on prend d'abord que prendre au quai
mais prend prend qu'est-ce-qui kesri
lornie ouais enfin on n'a pas raté grand
chose à y donne égal et cavaliers b5
maintenant mais honnêtement série web
rouge les finances étaient pas mal bon
retour nos directs mais ça semble être
un sens oui je suis d'accord mais je
n'évite pas les mille cavaliers e5 elle
va échanger
elle va reprendre du fou peut-être elle
va mettre la pression mais peut-être les
blancs et bonjour j'ai 3 maintenant il
faut j'ai deux parce que le four n'est
pas terrible ce rouge 3 je te bats ils
doivent faire je pense j'ai trois en
plus ils couvrent moyens techniques
bannissement
quelques dames b2 il va y avoir quoi
majorque a eu quatre balles près par
quoi ils préparent du d'un match 4 têtes
non je sais pas f5 g5 g4 on en voit dans
oui enfin franchement j'aime bien les
noirs encore mais j'ai l'impression que
tu avais comme il ya des pièces qui se
sont un peu échangé c'est peut-être
moins moins flagrant est à dire quoi
faites comme il ya moins de 10 à cet
avantage noir il a peut-être un peu
baissé maintenant c'est à dire un peu le
voile c'est de récupérer un peu le chat
pour avoir un peu notre ami tôt crasse
qui nous dit cavalli g5 des fois elle
c'est vrai que c'est pas idiot kg 5 peut
peut-être faire hcf 5 kg 5
parce que là où j'ai quatre des quatre
et on joue sur le cloud et c'est bon et
ouais on peut pas prendre
on est obligé de jouer à cognac a triché
nous maintenant des droits l'aca menaces
des deux maintenant oui ben non c'est la
cata ou pas mais c'est la partie ce la
partie ok mais là vanina faut pas qu'il
la rate si elle la rade c'est c'est la
cata le fou n'a plus de gaz à fin mai
20h contre j'ai peut-être
canon concordat est un pion qu'on donne
toutes les parties non mais là faut
vraiment qu'elle la gagne cela parce
qu'elle peut de toute façon faire des
deux fous b5 à tout moment et gagner la
call of wwii cavale et h7
bah oui elle va bon alors une qualité de
plus on est jeune prof
j'aime pas sans progression de chaque
moment mais elle va gagner âge qu'elle
gagne 1,4 à la fin en plus elle peut
faire tour des 8es prendre h 4 oui il ya
le car il était inquiet mal non ça va tu
vas faire d'un prend et cavaliers g5
bah non c'est parfait se passer est
complètement fini ça c'est également
pour les noirs c'est complètement
gagnant tu vas tu apprendras ch3 tu vas
encore déplacer les pions non mais c'est
horrible c'est fini alain gumiel on
trouve 25 ans donc qu'elle va juste en
caisse le pur h trois années en force à
être tombé à 8 bien joué aussi l'ajout
pour tourbe et un bon ça me paraît ça me
parait ça me parait terminé termina da
non mais tu vas faire quoi tu raques est
prêt je crois qu'ils ont prend tour b 1
dames ne gratte avec 4 attention ne pas
se rendre cavaliers f6 ya encore des
petites sièges j'ai pas compris ta ligne
non mais je voulais prendre verdun meuse
quatre tours ben ouais c'est quand même
faire attention de pas se prendre une
fourchette mais bon oui mais là c'est
3,2 points
ouais mais l'enfant est de zf 6 x 6 3 6
1 le même cours qu'à masquer un relief
trois dames jean matte bonté et froides
à mme german salaire assez convaincant
là enfin deux partout et valentina
valentina qui domine et qui s'est bien
ressaisi quand même après un début de
match
j'ai envie de dire poussive dans la
conclusion difficile difficile de
conclure mais mais elle conclu pour la
première fois et elle elle domine quand
même largement le match et joue plus
vite à présent ambühl est démente et ses
problèmes de connexion ça peut être ça
peut être un gros problème vrai parce
que elle est quand même assez souvent
déconnectés et l'hôtel ne semble pas ne
semble pas de bonne qualité donc un bon
française ouais je sens que je vais pas
trop de demandes et ton avis dans la
théorie dans la france est non j'ai
senti s'était pas mes dents que sais je
me rappelle soukhoumi âmes
je lève on n'est pas très longtemps je
ne me rappelle pas trop quoi faire
honnêtement donc cavalier e 2 et elle
prépare quoi elle prépare cavaliers f4
peut-être un jour cavaliers un pierre de
corail à cinq mois pour s'en prendre à
l'objet et je suis simple oui et elle va
jouer après pourrait peut-être jet4you 7
pardon il y aura le pion g7 qui sera
défendue dans ses positions très fermes
et qui sont pas évidente à jouer
non pas du tout je les trouve très
compliquée à jouer honnêtement pour
l'aide aux couleurs mais c'est pas c'est
pas évident non c'est pas du tout
évident peut-être mois après j'ai
toujours eu des bons résultats dans la
française même si toujours galvin
aujourd hui des mâles est joué mais je
sais que je joue bien normalement mais
avec les blancs et je sens bien la taxe
sur le roi en fait je n'arrive pas mal à
placer les pièces mais
mais c'est pas c'est pas vraiment super
naturel juste ça se passe bien quoi
parfois j'aimerais bien qu'ils avaient
lieu deux persos oui pour reprendre du
cavalier là dessus après corps ma vie
noailles comme lire 2 il faut prendre
quatre gros lycées 6
parce que sinon on doit jouer ses trois
je sais pas ok peut-être 30 sur des 4
quand je dis qu'à trier ses six essais 3
quand même et n'a pas peur que voilier à
tous 5 et 6
c'est ça ouais mais bon après c'est
chaud ouais mais j'ai pas trop les
ordres et je vous rends pas quoi faire
on ne peut pas bouger mon plan gg tout
pas détaillé comment vous allez partie
avec grand roque toujours une question
difficile avec les ventes savoir si tu
fais des quatre ici pour moi sur une
question tout genre b4 est ce qu'il faut
as tu veux faire comment la partie
chaque c'était d'être aux sciences parce
qu'ils ont un truc comme ça non avec le
truc en a six noms de ce fat avait une
idée comme ça et le truc c'est qu'il n'y
ait pas de cavalier genre là tu peux
plus voir la position mais mais ça va
pas être trop chance parce qu'il ya un
des deux je pense dans la partie mais
pas les deux appels aux dons via les
ressources est simple mais elle a fait p
en fait ça me fait pas trop peur de
bloquer les attaques personnelles avec
les blancs à l'anam parce que je me dis
qu'on va attaquer à l'endroit en fait
bon du coup qu'à valider 3 ok tu as
préparé à la trace à 4 à 5 la non oui
après à 4 à 5 et b5 sais pas si simple
pour les plans c'est pas si simple
d'ouvrir ma propre affaire qui est des
kataëb et trois fouilles 3 pouces et 5 à
3 tours de j'imite elle veut journée je
suis je pense pas ou les simples elle
veut bouger en tout cas les droits mais
j'ai envie de te dire on peut même faire
f4 d'un rêve de fou et 3 et est envoyé
comme ça oui parce que genre qu'est ce
que tu as vraiment faire genre tu vas
faire f4 affaires g6 admettons prix
quand je passais de me prendre comme ça
on fait damer f2 on me fout la honte à
elle pu ranger 3 qui sera protégé on
également contrôler non
oui ça va prend pousser encore un lâche
c'est pas forcément truc idéal pour pour
les blancs rock
ouah ça ça j'aurais passé quand même
personne je pense moi non plus mais
maintenant j'ai centre roger qu'une fois
en sept ans plus on va peut-être prendre
2 h n'en est comme ça on fera tout rage
suite damage sets à 1
oui non mais rock ça m'a paru quand même
un peu un peu spécial
oui je pense que cela donne une
possibilité pour les noirs pour trouver
des idées mais après peut-être que ses
pensées noires
en tout cas elle pousse à fond hockey /
f 4l affaire d'âme gk probablement et
oui après ça continue un peu de la
manière compenser la taxe blanche
manquer
alors mathieu qui nous dit que les
blancs pouvaient faire bouger 5 après
tout rejet limite pour la wii pour
complètement bloquée mais peut-être
enfin pour empêcher g5 et c'est bien
pour nous de changer ce four parce que
nous tous les pions son sang mais pas
vraiment quel jouet f4 hyper responsable
sur comprend d'un premier appareil a pas
fou g5 arrête donc elle peut pas elle
pouvait pas prendre les fous g5y et qui
enfilait non mais là complètement elle a
complètement perdu le contrôle là
au retour j'ai 4l manaslu hk peut-être
je sais pas si c'est grave mais fauché
quatre tours j'ai vu d'un gsm toi
moyenne qui allie qui tient la barre as
avec la dame en g7 en plus elle
attaquera le pion le pion aux cinq prime
ou non sa part et ça paraît ça parait
dur ça parait dur
mathieu qui 4 4 c'est une gaffe allait
sûrement puisque puis on prend et fou g5
qui arrive donc n'hésitez pas dans le
chat a imposé des questions tout ça là
comme s'était c'était la première fois
le premier événement qu'on commente avec
démentez pour un peu rentré dans le truc
c'est plus facile de pas à multiplier le
chat et tout ça mais petit à petit tu
vois on va rajouter des difficultés kg
en question est-ce que je m'entends bien
parce que j'avais encore interco en
commun des deux mondes micro n'ya pas
terrible en fait ton micro en tentant
bien mais les gens sont habitués à des
micros professionnels adacore m'en
veuillez pas professionnel thomas
microbes mais ça c'est pour ça pas
encore membre soit ils sont habitués à
des micros qui te faut y voir un petit
peu plus graves
d'accord mais je tenterai bien mais qui
peut lire n'hésite pas n'hésite pas à
prendre les commentaires à leur répondre
tu vois là si on commence à leur parler
ils vont ils vont ils vont me poser des
questions donc n'hésitant à 6 e qui te
poses des questions discutées avec eux
ils sont là quoi ils sont ils sont
partout quoi ils peuvent arriver
ils peuvent arriver il peut varier
rapidement leurs cavaliers f2 et la
partie est de 21 cents c'est très
compliqué mais je commence à aimer les
noirs à maintenant l autre la posture
des cadres et peut-être on la croit
qu'on va l'aider 5
donc je note un peu les questions qui
peut être intéressante et on les prendra
au début de la prochaine partie d'accord
donc ces quatre serait qu'à tout moment
suspect qui a aidé à 5 tu peux faire
tapis tu peux faire sauter dedans
ouais mais un fish est censé prendre mes
fans qu'elle me prend avec le courriel à
chipset dans la santé en train de partir
dans tous les sens là oui il a montré
que la punition
le truc attend c'est que tal cavagnan f4
qui tient salon wii donc on peut pas le
boulot mal bougé donc tu peux pas
découvrir
mais en fait c'est la seule pièce
blanche qui est vraiment défenseur que
tout le reste tu peux l'utiliser en
attaque
fondamentalement et côté noir un manteau
écrite
j'aime bien avant que sylvain larocque
est prise prise et je pense à la partie
rik daems et quatre non dame c4as mais
peut-être l'a pas fait parce que j'ai
besoin d'un psychiatre doit baisser mais
le pion sur l'affichette un prix ouais
mais si tu as aussi submergé de ouais
c'est vrai olala tour g4 a tant que
monde comment est-ce qu'on peut
aucunement répéter
oula être que je ne peux pas prendre sur
lui 2 je pense que tu dois envoyer un
temps voit les deux tours et tu prend
1,5 à la fin non et d'un dessin possi et
d'un local
ça paraît d'un jour pour maintenant dans
sa part être complètement gagnant non
genre tu prends un mec il ya plein fouet
ce cap à mes frais jusqu'à de foot et 6
us pour nice
non là c'est mort la manche et bonnet
blanc mat à droite à trois premiers
largeur x 4 pro dès 6 ans j'ai
complètement craqué voilà jean rouger le
contrarier de f4 ouais elle et par elle
est partie pour cette variante avait
fait cavalier h3 et mettait déjà des
trois des deux qui est jouable au pire
mais fou c'est s'être enquis ok tout
juste 5 4 en fait c'est horrible
peut-être tenté car il y avait six pour
mettre un peu de suspense au léger
simple sont d'accord et les psy show
mais il faut ok quoique pensée et noir
doivent être gagnant mais jure elle
donne un peu un peu de suspense quand
même dans ces 6es au 4ème en faut
prendre à ses paupières comprends pas ce
que je te prends avec le mcg peu moins
chaud surgissent avec arrêt juste avant
venait mais avec le jette donc à temps
j'ai promis que je prendrai des
questions intéressantes je me demande
quel est le poids des échecs en lituanie
c'est à dire quoi c'est c'est important
jean rend par exemple à l'école est ce
que laisse que tous les gamins tous les
enfants qui jouent aux échecs n'ont pas
tous mais
je sais qu'ils essaient de faire un
programme commun sur ce coup les échecs
agricole ouais il ya plus de douze
enfants qui apprennent à jouer mais
après au niveau c'est ce n'est pas
beaucoup de joueurs professionnels dans
mon pays malheureusement moins qu'en
france
ah oui beaucoup mais pour pourtant ce il
ya 15 20 ans c'était mieux on avait dans
ma mère est maintenant par ce nouveau
être un joueur professionnel et votre
fédération l aide beaucoup les joueurs
et des joueuses ou pas du tout non pas
du tout parce que les innombrables ils
n'ont pas beaucoup d'argent pour avoir
de l'argent il faut faire les bons
résultats dans les tournois officiels
comme les champions 1 0 les champions du
monde
s'ils gagnent mais n'est par exemple il
reste l'espoir l'argent de leur
gouvernement mais pas les résultats
comme ça c'est très difficile donc
donc vous n'êtes pas du tout aidé vous
n'avez pas de stages et entraînements ou
quoi que ce soit non donc ça veut dire
que au niveau niveau national en fait
les échecs c'est un peu comme en france
j'ai envie de revoir les journaux n'en
parlent pas même n'ont pas trop sauf si
3 imbriquant victoria et monétaires
pour jouer et essayer d'être bon pour
moi elle était la championne d'europe
elle a fini troisième dans le champion
du monde un chocolat il ya beaucoup de
beaucoup de nouvelles sur internet dans
le presse sur la télévision
mais si on situera un lien s'est il ne
pourra me dire ils vont pas parler
d'échec
il peut donc pas parler des trois quarts
alcen le machin là du monde pas comme
chez nous un tout petit peu mais pas ça
fait pas la une du journal quoi je pense
que il parle un peu de match de pau le
titre de champion de monde mais sinon
pas trop parce que dans mon pays c est
le boss quête qui est parce que le
basket ouais c'est le sport a un maire
en donc vous êtes basket à fond et vous
avez quoi d'autre et quoi d'autre bon
football j'imagine que partout au couple
et trois nuls ouais ouais mais après il
ya des sportifs dans l'affairisme par
exemple pas mauvais mais c'est plutôt
laisse le sport individuel et par
équipes mes jambes sont que vous êtes
grands noms j'ai toujours dit que les
lituaniens ces gens qui étaient grands
mais je suis pas si je sais pas on n'y
at on pas trop mais je comprends pas
d'où viennent tous ce genre de basket
oui vous escomptez am entités sont pas
du tout lituanien en fait ils sont
légers mais je sais pas je comprends pas
parce que c'est tout si tu me suis dit
on mange dans la route ou vois pas les
gens y parle mais dans son petit coin ou
normaux oui non et toi et toi t'es de
vilnius du coup non je viens d'une ville
qui s'appelle cholet ne s'est pas fait
un peu mieux pour les étrangers laissez
les grandes villes du coup c'est le
contraire lui l'amitié
c'est une merveilleuse de capital après
cette cour nas länder et cholet c'est
pas une petite ville quoi mais là je
sais pas 120000 d'habitants pas mal pour
lituanie et samarie mais pour la france
c
c'est engage pourtant j'habite dans une
île qui a soixante mille habitants
attention attention attention attention
ok c'est pas si petit garçon sur la
france un petit pays aussi parce qu'un
nom mais en russie tandis qu une ville
où il ya moins d'un million d'habitants
c'est une petite ville oui ça dépend
comment on part aussi du coup ils te
pose une question qui est se trouve
intéressante est ce qu'il ya une grosse
rivalité avec les autres pays baltes
grosse sais pas mais oui pendant
impression fait les jeux olympiques même
les tournants des chefs des fois on
essaie d'être meilleur que les pays
baltes a donc toujours les esto les
estoniens et lettons tu regardes oui je
ne finirai pas derrière elle et on s'est
vraiment solide et a donc un petit peu
mais bon ça c'est marrant parce qu'en
russie encore une fois comme j'habitais
longtemps mais on avait l'impression que
les gens des pays baltes sont des gens
très gentils
je sais pas tu un jour de stéréotypes
que c'est des gens gentils je sais pas
c'est difficile à dire je pensais un peu
con mandroux sied tout voir si tu vois
que dan dare dare où tu n'as pas
l'impression que c'est quelqu'un de
gentil mais si tu le connais bien commun
qui est en france par exemple tout le
monde est gentil dans la rue si tu
demande quelque chose et son bien et a
missionné sais tu de moi quelque chose
d'un coup c'est pas sûr que sa famille
très sympa mais surtout le premier est
bien il peut être sympa donc voilà on en
gardant tout la distance je vois tout à
fait est votre meilleur joueur genre le
joueur mythique lituanien d'échec ceux
qui parmi vous avez un joueur mythique
genre c'est pas votre meilleur joueur de
tous les temps des chèques
ah bon je sais pas on a aidé d'un
mentaliste
je connais il était très très fort bon
très très fort
et après en avoir deux smic and as tu
sais pas si je connais il ya même
endroit rien de mes canons
donc il vient de lituanie mais après par
exemple les tomes il il avait talent et
les estoniens il avait caresses donc on
n'a jamais eu une star comme ça avec lui
oui les estoniens ils ont aussi encore
élevé est je pense qu'ils jouent prix
noailles donc en fait vous êtes
complètement dans votre rivalité avec
les autres pays baltes vous êtes
complètement dépassés quoi et rés chez
les filles du coup c'est là où vous
dominez un peu les autres ah oui ça
c'est sûr je les fais on est on est
meilleurs qu'eux lettonie largement donc
on peut dire que les six sauts l'honneur
de la patrie ouais mais c'est marrant
parce que victor whitmill était allée
bien au dessus de ma ville de cholet
voilà c'est cholet qui fait qui fait
tout le truc exemple temps maintenant je
sais pas malheureusement il n'y a pas de
jeune fille qui est qui peuvent
remplacer qui peuvent être si forte
comme par exemple victoria c'est vous
on va mais les filles ne sommes pas très
intéressant par les échecs et vous avez
une
une relève chez les hommes chez les
garçons où dur aussi dans tout l'est
tous les compartiments
vous avez des nouveaux des nouveaux
jeunes qui arrivent chez les garçons
chez les garçons c'est un petit mieux
parce que il ya quelques gens qui sont
un premier temps par exemple on a un
jeune qui a je n'ai pas dit ce qu'il a
dit en jeu crois mais il s'appelle pour
le sporting richesse que l'animé il se
qualifiait pour le coupe de monde chez
les mecs parce qu'il a très très bien
joué dans le championnat d'europe
parce que là et donc c'était un gros
surprise mais je suis très content pour
lui parce que c'est pas souvent qu'on a
quelqu'un qui jouait dans le groupe le
monde est au niveau de l'école d'échecs
vous avez quoi c'est une école genre
écoles soviétique dans l'enseignement
gensse a pas vraiment de rapport n'est
pas en d'entraîneur genre à la
soviétique pas trop comment reprendre à
cette question les trois ça va être
juste l'école
bah ouais non mais tu sais pas je suis
beaucoup les parties de boules vinik ces
machins c'est une tout ça les finales
oui oui on peut le dire par exemple
les entrepreneurs que j'avais et il m'en
faut bosser beaucoup sur les routes ce
qui aiderait les parcs des champions du
monde des finales tout ça après je mets
en ce moment je ne sais pas trop si les
nouveaux entraîneurs travaillent paris
est il son genre très strictes gentils
nous en europe on a l'image des
entraîneurs des pays de l'est comme des
gens qui sont très strictes un peu oui
et encore oui je sais pas c'était un peu
plus sérieux que je vois par exemple en
france parce que en français je échec
c'est pour s'amuser je fais de temps et
moi quand j'étais petite je voulais
toujours joué pour le résultat n'était
pas juste pour porter mon week end pour
deux jeux pour gagner quoi
oui c'est ça mais tu joue toujours pour
gagner d'ailleurs je te vois quand même
quand tu joues en trop de chats sig avec
nous ce qui est semi amical et sans que
toi ton sens que les nous on est venu
pour rigoler et toi tu es venu pour
gagner en fait on sent la différence
oui je veux toujours gagner et si je
perds je m'énerve énormément je pense
beaucoup trop souvent et par exemple
poitiers smic
ça me rend folle parce que si je joue
mal après j'ai du mal à m'endormir parce
que j'y pense commenge de jouer ce
témoin alors pourquoi j'ai parlé cette
partie mais après j'ai bien joué
non mais c'est marrant parce que ça se
sent assure la caméra quand on doit ça
se sent vraiment c'est très marrant
quand tu joues c'est hyper expressive et
quand tu perds ça se voit que tu es très
énervé en fait ouais j'ai très bien joué
mais je ne sais pas pourquoi je suis
comme ça je sais depuis mon enfance
j'étais comme ça je chante faux quand
j'ai perdu en deux parties je pleurais
tout le temps c'était horrible quand
même des fêtes fin de fin de monde à s
est dur c'est dur c'est dur elle va du
coup tu peux utiliser à face du mur tu
as peur tu as une 10 avant les parties
une phrase que j'aimais bien c'était
gagné une partie oui
en fait tu dois connaître le film russe
des ratés stolow 12 chaises
oui je le connais mais je pense pas que
j'allais en fait il ya une phrase est en
ondes et un mec qui parle en français il
y chercher la femme est connue et donc
une surface quand ils arrivent en france
il parlait pas bien français et il
pensait qu'on pouvait dire un verbe à
l'infinitif et un mot tu vois il pensé
que c'était c'était du français normal
de qualité quoi donc c'est pour ça
qu'ils disent est des fois je vois quand
je réfléchissais longtemps sur un coup
pour jouer quelque chose j'en ris comme
moi ça m'arrivait de réfléchir genre 40
ou 50 minutes oui mis en place après la
partie mise et jouer un coup c'est des
phrases comme ça j'adore quoi gagner une
partie jouée un coup il voulait en fait
joué un coup de fer juge joue plus vite
tu joues un coup et puis voilà
mais j'en ris pour lui tu vas jouer un
coup c'est genre une phrase et gagner
une partie ces genres son conseil avant
la partie salon la partie il te dit
gagner une partie quoi d'accord ouais
mais tu as tout compris
ouais et pas le troisième conseil avant
le tournoi de blitz conseil très
important joue vite et bien
c'est des bons conseils ça tu vois ça te
moi tu sais quoi faire avant tu es parti
non mais ça paraît bête de dire à
shawville mais en fait c'est un bon mois
d'entraînement il me dit toujours comme
ça mais c'est toujours bliss je ne
réfléchis pas juste à main et sfr les
beaucoup donc quand on commence à
réfléchir en plus c'est pas bien donc je
vais vite je suis dedans dit à monsieur
intuition oui mais vite mais tue à lui
rajoute pas bien tu as bu la tasse pour
jouer vite et bien ça c'est encore le
niveau au dessus
ça c'est encore le niveau au dessus et
piétons entraîneur du coup est-ce que
c'est mathieu cornette
ah oui mais maintient connaissent bien
et qui a été tourné entre l'entraîneur
le plus marquant qui t'a le plus marqué
dans ta carrière
mise à part mathieu mais je peux dire
violent mais je pense pas que les gens
l'école connaissent pas ce que c'est les
entraîneurs lituaniens on va dire ton
entraîneur qui t'a le plus tu vois le
turban marron s'est ouverte à ce qui m'a
le plus marqué parce qu'on est on est
resté très copains tu vois après il m'a
juste marquer en général tu vas plus
qu'en tant qu'entraîneur mon temps comme
presse quoi on va dire si tu devais a
mise à part mathieu qui est hors
catégorie
mais quel engin qui avait le plus marqué
mais peut-être même pas contente contre
et noir tu vois comme inspiration pour
ta carrière
oui c'est vrai la première conseil
s'appelle gemena cela stiles il va
permettre internationale mais
il est un très bon entraîneur il a passé
aussi avec talent et humilité et j'ai
bossé avec lui aussi et il m'a donné
beaucoup de conseils
il a aussi travaillé avec victoire du
peuple
et oui c'est un entraîneur qui m'a
beaucoup donné je trouve
il m'a appris comment travailler sur les
échecs et et il est il est un très bon
psychologue aussi qui est très important
dans les écrits monaco et du coup tu
avais quel niveau quant à u 7 cet
entraîneur je pense je commence c'est
pas rejeté un maître international
camino et après je suis devenu un grand
maître et après je sortais je sais pas
pourquoi c'est génial en fait c'est à
dire que l'on fait c'est précis les
pouces il écoute le stream
il faut qu'ils te recontacte qu'enfin
ces dames et on s'y tient ferme mais
juste voir et je n'avais pas beaucoup de
lettres de la fédération donc c'était
toujours moi qui devais payer et je
pense honnêtement je n'avais pas
beaucoup d'argent pour travailler pour
continuer à travailler avec lui je
pensais arrêter un peu mais maintenant
on se dit encouragé par mes parts et et
ça fait beaucoup plaisir parce que c'est
toujours sympa de savoir qu'il ya
quelqu'un qui le battait partie de ses
portes tout ça alors on demande dans le
chatt combien d'heures tu t'entraînes
par semaine pour être au top niveau
honnêtement je suis d' entre feignants
qui s'y passe je sais pas je sais pas
j'aime bien venir les exos les études
comme ça j'ai pas trouvé les énergies
mais je les travaille beaucoup pendant
l'e3 je trouvais beaucoup de jeunes a
pendant le tournoi parce que j'aime bien
vous prépariez d'être bien préparés pour
la porter et sinon oui ça dépend j'ai
jamais vraiment eu le régime sportif je
me lève je fais ça deux heures je fais
ça trois heures mais tu attends la
période du travail et beaucoup tu devais
tu te fais quand même enchaîné des arts
j'imagine il ya une période petit pour
décorer les autres qui j'ai déjà
travaillé beaucoup et c'était par
exemple quand je suis allé à 2,9 pour
travailler avec mon entraîneur dit si
c'est vous si cette heure par jour et
c'était vraiment très difficile mais je
pense que c'est quand il joue c'est
important de faire les entraînements
concerne parce que c'est comme ça que tu
progresses vraiment quoi oui oui oui tu
es fatigué mais maintenant en a marre
mais bon tu progresses hammamet sa tête
de progresser donc mal donc c'est là que
tu as un peu fait la différence
oui et du groupe et mathieu lui par
exemple il s'entraîne beaucoup enfin il
s'entraîner beaucoup je sais
mathieu trahi vraiment beaucoup que nos
noms en général avant maintenant je sais
pas quand même pas le travail mais avant
j'ai toujours eu l'impression que
mathieu il bossait énormément les échecs
non je pense l intérieur qui ne pas
boire faire de tous il m'a dit ça il
sait jamais a travaillé un peu mais j'ai
dit à mathieu c'est quelqu'un qui aime
beaucoup les échecs ils regardent les
échecs tous les jours et je vois toutes
les parties
ils souhaitent tous les tournois et pour
lui c'est juste je sais pas si on peut
dire qu'ils travaillent ici le second
revient et analyse des partis mais c'est
un coût des matières c'est incroyable
non mais vous n'imaginez pas avec tous
les jours je viens au salon je me lève
je viens souvent et je vois que femme de
20 ans et déjà le mais qu'elles sont
pièce basse et déjà rouvert
est-ce qu'on est ce qu'on peut dire que
c'est un mini vlad je sais pas qu'est ce
que tu veux dire exactement un mini vlad
c'est quelqu'un qui connaît beaucoup de
choses oui
du coup c'est un mini vlad
oui c'est comme ça un petit bla dans la
maison et oui quand elle fait les vidéos
par exemple ça se voit qu'ils
s'intéressent beaucoup aux échecs qui
souhaitent tout je suis d'accord toutes
les interviews
ah oui c'est tout ce matin on a fait la
vidéo il avait vu les interviews il
avait tout vu mais franchement train
pour pour honnêtement quand tu fais des
vidéos travail avec mathieu c'est un
plaisir ni même mois non mais c'est un
plaisir c'est en fait ils arrivent il a
tout vu il a tout regardé
enfin c'est impressionnant en fait
c'était tu es là tu es fou et pourtant
moi je regarde aussi parce que je fais
des vidéos et tout donc je me renseigne
un peu quand même pas des fois j'ai pas
le temps parfois j'ai le temps et quand
je me suis renseigné
de toute façon je sais que match nul ce
sera plus facile sera plus que moi en
fait oms est un avantage il ne se force
pas de faire ça pas moi si je je me part
ça je dois me forcer
alors que ce qui fait qu'on va laisser
un minimum de plaisir avec la
définissent en fait qui est marrant tu
sais que s'il travaille beaucoup les
échecs il le cache
il fait semblant qu'il ne fait pas un
alors ça je sais pas en tout cas avec
moi il le fait peut-être parce qu'ils
pensent que comme moi je bosse pas trop
les échecs tu vois que je lui parle plus
de rap le truc comme ça il veut tu dois
être un peu dans le mouv tu vois mais il
arrive à vlad il arriva blad de me
mentir je te jure sur son emploi du
temps pour me cacher qu'il analyse et
les échecs lna c'est exceptionnel donc
ce n'est pas en train de nous dire je
travaille pas trop en fait tu travailles
beaucoup tu nous fais pas ce que
j'appelle une blague certain sens avant
que tu bosses tu en mets deux il ya des
gens qui ne veulent pas dire qu'ils
travaillent beaucoup parce que s'il ne
réussit pas à faire des bons résultats
tu vois ce que je veux dire c'est ed que
je travaille beaucoup et ne l'auriez pas
ça peut être un peu bizarre way est
possible je ne travaille pas après y
être pour le magic pour la cgt me
comprendre ta mais juste comme souvent
quand je parle à des gens qui sont forts
ils disent qu'ils travaillent pas trop
tu vois c'est un peu c'est un peu
frustrant quoi porte
bon alors cette partie du coup ça donne
quoi alors on a déjà raté un parking way
qui a été gagné par valentina j'ai fait
deux trois flèches à un moment donné
d'accord et là qu'est ce qu'on en a
assez et lina qui qui peut peut-être
faire quelque chose
mouais je pensais le roi qui va rentrer
en quoi b3g pas compris aof
mais quand même il me rejoindre à 4 mais
c'est un peu exagéré non au caire tous
rêvent 3 c'était possible donc c'était
c'est pour ça qu'elle jugeait cas
d'abord peut-être f3 là maintenant tout
est je crois maintenant je pense que
c'est pas bête
ouais ouais non ça va venir ouais c'est
comme les gens qui qui qui qui dit
qu'ils ont pas bosser avant les exams et
qui te tape un 15 sur 20 et c'est ça ça
ça m'a toujours énervé aussi ah oui mais
bon après ils disent nous on n'a pas
bossé tous après les mecs c'est ça il te
tape des trucs qui connaissent tous et
en a marre bon alors ça ça fait nul
quand même fait un petit échec et un roi
est comme ça aussi ça va fermer
mais je n'aurais pas fait ça comme ça ok
monsieur farewell froid turek six
semaines ça serait génial je suis 3g 3g
8 dames mon bail mais bon ça aurait été
marrant
bon alors il attend il reste combien de
temps la danse et danse et 5 puis saint
parce qu'on parle on parle on parle il
reste on dit c'est la dernière partie
normalement de 11 + 1 et après un homme
qui pose et après une petite pause de
cinq minutes et ça c'est une bonne
nouvelle on va pouvoir récupérer et on
va permettre une page de pub la
publicité c'est très très bien ça c est
très intéressant
donc moi toujours cette honda annoncé
une nouvelle qu'on est nouvelle
ouverture écoute on a une anglaise 1 et
on va avoir encore des pions pendant
mais cette fois ci pour les blancs 1 un
terrain
donc c'est une autre c'est une autre
couleur alors attends je vérifie juste
qu'on soit bien
sois bon ok donc est-ce qu'on est le il
va faire comment tu penses avec les
noirs rb6 vous bessette a je sais pas
j'ai réfléchi wayne possibilité de
poursuivre le vrai tour d'eric fouda 7
pour 1 8 où s'ébattent en france mais si
c'est plus logique le soudain la tête
on en a beaucoup vu aujourd'hui des des
fous qui revenant des deux ans au 1 28 7
la tour eiffe des huit tours assez vite
qui va rigoler ans rachid peut-être un
jour j'ai quand même l'impression que
les problèmes de connexion de vanina
influe sur le match parce que tu vois
elle est souvent déconnectés elle est
quand même bien dans le match
c'est dommage mais c'est dommage respect
est un vrai problème
regardez vite tour assez aimée et encore
une fois j'avais peu joué avec cavaliers
à saint caprais
mais tu vois c'est marrant parce que
tout à l'heure c'est c'est vanina qui
avait les les pions pendant et c'est
elle qu'on préférait et là je trouve que
les tours qui sont meilleures places
parce que marc hérite
voilà près d'amman tout à fait logique
de mettre nos torts à 50 jours je ne
sais pas comment ça marche si ça marche
tu mènes peut être vidé à et après oui
c'est les plans de jeu le fond mais ça a
l'air tout à fait correct le cavalier
qui peut peut-être venir un jour sur des
4 d'ailleurs moi mais à droite on va
faire quoi
bah ouais mais pas tout de suite je sens
un milliard sur ici à fabriquer des
cartes et fougueux quatre mais cinq pour
le moment
un peu du rêve mais les plans et ce qui
permet à huit mois
peut-être pour ces villes comme je sais
pas mais des fois il faut se méfier donc
on va réagir au pain non on a juste
poussé way qui avec à sa tête un souci
est ce qu'elle peut tenter de jouer est
un truc avec damas d'un fou un fois je
suis pas de place pour une pièce des
blancs sais pas mais c'est faux a dit
non j'ai bien dessins en noir elle
change de la structure d'options je
pense qu'elle a raison honnêtement mais
bon après ce que ça va fonctionner
concrètement
peut-être que avec les manches pour soi
juste voir pousser tes pieds tu vas
juste vouloir pousser les pions en aide
aux personnes jeunes et moins jeunes au
défunt quand je vois tout bêtement et
les blancs je vois pas trop où est ce
qu'il faut pas qu'ils prennent à eux
cinq pour essayer de te mettre la
d'amoureux cinq verges et trois quand
même essayer d' un peu joué sur sur la
diagonale au mans comme alien 3 dames 1
non je vais faire que les produits
sanguins province 1 kg 3 peut-être
essayé mais bon après ça chez moi je
suis pas grand chose en réalité il faut
pousser leur 4 4
je sais pas dans un deuxième temps à
voir ce qu'elle a fait elle a fait
cavalier h4 à c'est ma bête ça c'est pas
des vrais parce que vous poussiez le cas
peut-être un jour et e4 ou pas est-ce
qu'on peut jouer je laisse ici si je
suis je suis bien tenté partait le coup
et des fois non on n'a pas connu
bon admettons ça et ça non pour prendre
un café
ouais bien vu donc ça marche pas de
faire une course de kart directement
elle a fait qu'elle prend des 50 ans
alors là à un écolier est symbolique et
f5 d'un v6 un peu on y vend tout mais
ouais on défend tout ça va quand même
être chaud parce qu'il peut y avoir
aussi des trucs en g7 qui traînent tu
vois ya peut-être dû peut-être du f4 ici
oui et yahia fou prend g7 qui peut
arriver à un moment donné enfin deux
variantes
est ce qu'on peut faire convoyer des
soins pour des fins quelqu'un qu'on
pouvait être le cas vaillant mais bon
mais en des 100 g 6 f ou g 4 à sa part
est hyper dangereux parce que tu as qui
prend 1,6
tu menaces qu'elle prend des six
peut-être un peu aussi ont partagé cet
avis car ouest où après un poids 2 mais
je sais pas si c'est ça dont quelque
chose à fouad wendat b2o annonces
arrivent de partout la réécoute 5 et
lequel rejouer f4 et que tu as peut-être
faire f 4 1 ça paraît très dangereux en
tout cas ça paraît très dangereux la f4
avec le avec la diagonale à à un g7
oui c'est ça
cavalier prend des six alors attends il
ya peut-être un dame prend tu peux pas
parce qu'il ya eu 4 donc tout reprend
force et nous quatre quand même et fois
dont deux fois deux tours des foyers
autour des 6 ça a fonctionné
vous même tous réussissent donc tu dois
faire quoi fou p7 disons le autrement je
mets ton truc ça me paraissait fort je
pense pas que tout le monde est de
concevoir des fils lorsque le corps
lettre simple mais j'ai l'impression
qu'elle a perdu beaucoup de son activité
dans oui c'est comme si eux
en plus c'est un pion un pion plus pour
les noirs oui j'allais vous et de jouer
sur le mois puis on arrive ici c'est
talent fou de cases blanches pour
couvrir les cases blanches au cas où
donc sur noir tu es tranquille et a même
des cavaliers g6 qui avait dit f 4 à
tanger est un petit oeil sur le chrono
il reste 4 8 heures peut-être que voici
la partie finit vite y en aura une
deuxième des ruines d une dernière une
der des ders hamel henin elle est encore
très mal au dos disputant la kg 6 n'ont
menacé les pions et son père adam g 3.8
vraiment même le pion à quatre reprises
non mais ça c'est longueuil québec
iprefq 4 4 mais ça m'a l'air d'être
complètement terminée il ya le fou qui
arrêtent être attaqué le pion j'ai deux
emprunts serait 5 cl d'eau font mouche
comprend 100 kw est d'alger synchro la
belle va tomber non et 5 pour refermer
le fou notamment chez et en mai nasdaq
ça gagne autant valentina qui prend le
lead démonter c'est la première fois
qu'elle mène au score
c'est ce que je crois
c'est ici c quatre et demi à trois ans
et demi c'est en dessous de l'échiquier
c'est la première fois que valentina
mène elle franchement elle joue beaucoup
mieux et le dominant elle domine
largement
il ya le domine largement alors attends
je regarde je récupère un peu le tchad
ont ça discute un petit peu de commandes
progresser aux échecs on a laissé parler
tranquillement et donc on a de nouveau
cette pause a qualifié 5 menace mater
menace le fourbe et 7 mai - 5
non mais ça va pas loin et vous pranger
5 aurait été marrant c'est parce que des
des fois les pièges comme ça ça fait
rire tout de suite pour les morts ouais
et là mais j'aime bien les blancs quand
rien je peux te dire tu veux faire ça 84
tu fais ça qu'on va t elle changer on va
te mettre une tour en d1 oui oui j'ai
envie de te dire j'ai envie de te dire
est encore toujours en fait je peux tu
as tu juste fan de valentina tu vois et
un truc quoi a toujours d'une bonne
position mais à l'affût le 3 et des
canons mais c'est bien ce qu'elle fait
en fait oui je sais pas mais elle ne
veut pas mettre le pion soulagement
non franchement franchement c'est encore
superposition mais tu penses quand tu
quand tu es mal préparés comme ça tu
gères comment quand a que des mauvaises
positions à la sortie de l'ouverture ça
t'arrive dans des tournois ou schumann
mais je sais pas pourquoi mais quand
j'ai des mauvaises positions et
et je suis pas content je suis assez
détendu parce que je me dis bon droit de
perdre mais très souvent je bats et je
lui aussi à m'en sortir
des fois je vais au cinéma gagné
l'évolution comme ça mais c'est pas très
agréable enjoué mais du coup ça t'enlève
une pression d'être mal oui c'est un
livre la pression parce que je me dis
bon on va peut-être perdre donc fais de
ton mieux et juste fait ce que tout
homme donc
et quand je suis sans que j'aime
composition et je peux jouer paulo gansa
me parce que il faut retrouver les
complices y souvent pour gagner la
partie et j'ai tu te trompes pas ça peut
te lâcher l'habitat mais n'a pas envie
de rater des occasions parce qu'il y en
a tellement peu pesé chaque des bonnes
positions sorties l'ouverture mais
est-ce que tu remarques que c'est
souvent plus difficile de faire un geste
impression là personnellement c'est
quand tu joues condé jean plus fort ils
sont souvent aussi plus fort dans les
ouvertures genre vas tu vois par exemple
pourquoi d'exemple betts et valentina je
pense qu'elle est juste un peu plus
forte que dina lapointe général voilà
100 points l'autre plus est juste a
l'impression que dans ces cas là bas le
le joueur qui à 100 points de vue s'il
va être dit va dominer les ouvertures
quoique joueurs plus forts généralement
il donne une ouverture - est peut-être
un général sont comme ça mais ça normal
parce que c'était plus fort c'est à dire
que peut-être travail pluzz pour aller
plus de pioche
non mais pas sur quelque chose que
j'avais l'impression comme ça c'est que
les joueurs plus forts étaient souvent
aussi plus fort dans les ouvertures dans
les matches comme ça sur tous les matchs
lotus où il ya beaucoup de parties n'ont
peut-être
[Musique]
du coup cette position-là à ben ali
najab son qu'elle s'est quand même pas
mal reprise non au final ouais
hier par le passé ces pièces et le fou
thual a réussi à vider la diagonale ça
j'aime bien ce qu'elle a fait il n'y a
plus vraiment de banquets ou deux c'est
bien joué je pense mais peut-être un
jour des saints qui est aussi ceci oui
bah non c'est pas mal joué bon du coup
avec les noirs comment tu fais ça sans
réfléchir
est ce qu'on fait après après coralie a
qu'un pas que je n'en voyais juste des
formations à notre bagage et bien en
cocktail notamment saint bernard cahen
v101 pas beaucoup 13 ans tout soit tu
vends un sacré durant ces 60 à 3,15 en
gros mais août à ces six hommes jugés
possibles menaces peut-être des cinq
maintenant
enfin ça peut traîner collègues b6 est
ce que c'est de jouer simple il domine
depuis août elle le donne à cesser les
parties c'est la partie qui est je
prends toute façon on n'a pas le choix
si elle prend pas elle fait quoi toi 4
rebonds non mais bien je comprends pas
ok mb 3 tempo prison
ok elle attaque ça glissait de fond
qu'est née cette dame six âgées pas mais
alors écart est liée à huit fois à 8,1
me 6 dames f5 aussi au pire un à dix
c'était hyper beau ça hyper bien jouer
ou non mais valentina quand elle devient
chaude là comme ça quand elle joue bien
c'est fou quoi elle trouve des trucs
vraiment elle est vraiment forte
oui ou non elle est impressionnante
quand même démonté moi m'impressionne
valentina non mais oui d'accord mais des
fois il fait des bêtises je me connais
partie médiane importe quoi donc
non mais elle peut faire mes jambes sont
que ce format là où ça joue longtemps
c'est un format qui lui convient
parfaitement
j'aurai les atteindront 2 ainsi elle est
un bonne humeur c'est là d'énergie ça va
bien dormez elle peut gagner tous mes
n'aime pas faire les très mauvais score
au pied bon il suffit que j'ai dit ça
pour faire la paperie ion il ça fait
quel effet 4 je veux demander ce n'est
pas qu'elle éprouve aussi c'est fou des
cinq en fait attend l âge de convoler
femme pourquoi elle n'a pas pris à 8 je
sais pas mais c'est sûr puisque j'ai dit
qu'elle joué super bien et du coup il
fallait que mais je tenais des voix elle
fait des bêtises
c'est à dire parfois il fait des bêtises
mais elle joue vite tout le temps en
fait elle en a absolument rien à faire
elle est jamais en contrôle mais ça je
ne comprends pas un peu trop vite et
leur fléchit pas mais peut-être l'acteur
de sa connexion que perd donc son café
sans parti l'on vous aussi dans la fois
plus des fois non content impôts et
quand l'un des perdants mais commence
avec les chiens donc bon elle est quand
même bien à la villa d'amont b6
oui je préfère tallinn avec foucault
invités d'emprunt si c'est d'en prendre
parce que maintenant je trouve que le
petit problème en fait c'est que ça ça
peut être bien lui quoi mais bon pour 5
5 mais c'est passionnant
c'est en échange le photographe aliens à
te noies pas me laisser faire ça aux
saintes avant d'être embarqués c'est la
partie statutaire les mamans c6 non j'ai
pas ce qu'elle veut faire mais elle veut
faire des trucs non monsieur comprendre
peut-être à la hauteur de damas est
peut-être
ouais mais là la toile est en train de
préparer t il prend des cinq gars à qui
tombe à la fin
ouais ouais bon après c'est peut-être
fait apprendre du cavalier faut prendre
un problème si ce tour s'est vite et se
battre un peu quoi il y aura de thann
des cathares en d5 tant matériellement
on en est où
quand voilier un peu ce qu'il faut pour
prendre c'est ça voyez comme on peut
emporter tout voilà un pion plus déjà
peut-être d'amd si si si ah oui ça me
prend plus on prend qu elle attendait 5
non mais là il ya tout là elle va gagner
elle va gagner c'est sûr ou pas presque
non mais sera pas une immanence a gagné
au prochain ok je la plains prend fou 10
à la finale de pions ce pas si sûr
qu'elle soit gagnante aux copains parce
que revient aussi sur le pion je vais
vers un point de vue que leurs noms mais
bon le genre humain
non elle joue plus donc là c'est la
pause 5 min 5 minutes donc tu peux tu
peux tu peux tu peux tu peux ne pas être
opposé j'aimais aller à venir demain on
voit restos
minutes seront démontés a d'autres moi
je vais vous mettre une petite pub
pendant ce temps et après on va revenir
pour le 3 + 1 alors attendez je galère
un petit peu parce que j'ai un petit
problème de dernière minute tout à
l'heure quand on a lancé le live mais ça
va bien se passer
t'inquiète pas ça va bien se passer bien
se passer de tincques y est pas donc la
pub on va l'envoyer et je vous dis on se
retrouve dans cinq minutes a tout de
suite les mecs
[Musique]
donc les amis on est de retour avec des
montées qui nous a pas quittés à la
pause elle est revenue on a forcément
parce que qu'est-ce qu'on ait des
sauvages ou pas dans ça nous ne sommes
pas des sauvages et donc on va se
retrouver pour cette deuxième partie
donc là à démonter pour t'expliquer les
règles comme c'est la première fois que
tu commentes on change de cadence on
passe en 3 + 1 d'accord mais mais si tu
veux ça a la même importance
c'est tous ces genres il n'ya pas y'a
pas de ça il n'y a pas des moindres les
points ne comptent pas plus ou moins
c'est à dire que tu joues en 5 + 1 3 + 1
1 plus 1 c'est le même comptage
simplement on va jouer que 60 minutes
ici et la cadence avant c'était une
heure trente
tout à l'heure à la fois rock et donc ça
ce jour d'une heure et après le vol est
le but let's à jour à 30 minutes
dacquois ok donc en fait c'est fait pour
pour pour que pour qu'il y aura peu près
autant de parties en réalité d'accord
oui c'est l'idée quoi mais en pratique
en pratique
ouais non c'est à peu près ça en fait
les toutes les cadences sont à peu près
la même valeur parce que en fait on te
dis toujours oui mais les bullet ça va
être important tu sais y'a quelqu'un qui
va écraser l'autre est en réalité
souvent celui qui a dominé le match et
domine et dominer pu être qu'un jour je
perds c'est un genre de truc
psychologique qui se passe soit pendant
le match
oui j'en retiens à peu pris le dessus et
du coup en fait cet avantage
psychologique où je sais pas comment on
peut le on peut on peut le
la plaie tu vois mais il reste en fait
d'abord et c'est vraiment parce que j'ai
fait un tournoi il y à du jour à saint
pétersbourg c'était un peu ma famille
landolt rapide et il y avait les
maquillages qui a joué là bas aussi
et elle a dit je dois m'entraîner un
bullet parce que c'est très important
pour le spécial serait donc je pense
qu'elle s'est entraîné mais bon on va
voir comment ça se passait mais en fait
évidemment et c'est important mais
vraiment c'est le truc c'est que tu
étais le match avant ça te laisse quand
même une marque quoi oui oui quand tu es
habitué au style de l'autre et tu mets
quelque part tu ta les ouvertures qui
sont déjà en place et ça ça ça donne un
peu le ton le ton du match donc
alors qu'est ce que c'est que cette
position là c'est quand même un peu
spécial dans ce grand roque
ouais ça me fait un auteur pour le
nombre de jeux coussin bah ça me fait
même super peur ouais je sais pas tu as
quand même palmarès des noirs tu vas tu
as tout et pion qui sont sous pression
non mais pourquoi elle a joué dans 27
ans joue comme ça c'est qu'il faut voir
tôt cros - josse pourront faire non tu
es pas plutôt d'annoncer cette note
naturellement je veux dire oui moi je
reste à la maison
en côte-d'or temps fou bloc et des
quatre alors beckett b5 ça m'a fait
encore bon voilà je pensais sait
qu'atteindre non je pense que maintenant
c'est ce que tu disais elle est capable
du meilleur comme du pire mais oui c'est
ça le problème
des fois elle veut tellement bien je
personnes voulaient arrêter mais des
fois elle fait des bêtises attentats pas
non je voulais faire tv5
moi je suis complètement fou mais mais
là tu veux juste faire b4 et qu'il prend
le 4 nom déjà
ouais c'est catastrophe
tournehem pourquoi je crois des cadres à
eux deux ont prises à la fin oui mais
non mais là j'ai pas tu sens qu'il ya un
truc mais juste faut trouver mais au
tibet capte jour où déjà si tu joues
coralie un sujet tokoin et prendre le
pinceau assez à manger peut pas parce
qu'il y avait 6 le fou voilà réussi à se
forger 6 mai vous avez quatre baies 5 y
va quand même arriver ou p4c 5,27 océan
je pense pour but d'aider à près de 5
elle va envoyer non mais les noirs j'ai
du mal à voir comment ils peuvent
envoyer le jeu allait le dab aller le
roi pardon ils s'en vont
il n'y a pas non il n'y a pas de jeu du
tout leforest juste des aides sans
justice et je suis de formation donc à
es17 qu'est ce qu'elle veut faire
je pense est là encore de b4 mais bon
peut être que valeo 5 et le faire mais
ça l'est pourront alors là par contre je
suis quand même très inquiet pour
valentina parce que sa connexion a pris
un sale coup elle n'arrête pas de se
déconnecter
ça aurait pu mais bon c'est un jour
quand léo 5 tab et trois logiques
peut-être au décès de ses yeux rouges
pour liquider sur les sites idée sur la
colonne des ouais je sais pas je sais
pas trop quoi faire
robbery ça peut être en cours oui elle a
retourné mais attendait cette tour
déliter et pour liquider les tours ouais
c'est pas évident c'est pas évident du
tout pour pour valentina ici non mais
les blain et donne aussi le trône est
beau monde à callac enfin tv5 et là y'a
pas du cavalier prend à cet éperon 6 to
one oui ça peut marcher mais ça marche
elle a trouvé annoncé non c'est moi qui
ait sévi à redon c'est génial mais ça va
marcher ouais ça le fait non non non tu
pense que c'était un match un peu choqué
aussi
non mais c'est toujours quand on voit
les médecins ne peut pas les manières
ses droits et là y'a pas tout reprendre
et 4 c'est pas une pièce non mais les
filles arrêtées non mais attends attends
je vais juste ordi c'est peut-être nous
qui sommes complètement fou par exemple
si tu prends des quatre systèmes restent
non mais suite à la l1
n'ont pas vu les deux les deux les deux
font une très mauvaise partie là oui
c'est déjà fatigués ou qu'est-ce qui se
passe non mais c'est peut-être c'est
peut-être juste une mauvaise partie quoi
la reprise mais mais c'est assez assez
surprenant quand même là non mais
surtout flou f4 cavaliers h5 nom et ma
fille rentre aussi en revue le concours
jusqu'à la gare mais là je pense que je
pensais juste une mauvaise partie quoi
du coup quand les deux les deux joueurs
jouent mal après ils s'entraînent à mal
jouer les uns les ans l'un et l'autre et
la savoie pour les normands non moi
j'aime bien les noirs page d'amérique
duarte une qualité de moi mais tu
reviens un peu quoi tu vas faire fouet
cette façon mcg cinq mois et le temps on
regarde annonay annoncé incroyable
incroyable incroyable des montées contre
elle ne peut pas jouer comme ça lui
apporte in non mais là c'est un gros
regarde regarde regarde la caméra tu as
vu à l'heure c'est n'a pas content non
mais là il a raté mais mes et valentina
là tout le temps la même tête assez
extraordinaire elle opère son adversaire
vraiment difficile quoi il fait une
seule tête du début à la fin elle tu
écrases elle repart elle fait la même
tête c'est génial elle a une tête quoi
ouais c'est fantastique
on joue vraiment pas malin et talât
merkel synphot jeter à l'eau et aux
émotions
moi je me sens que c'est un film
d'horreur de viol contre elles par leur
état était têtu tu vois les films
d'horreur pas toujours un méchant qui
fait toujours autant la même tête et qui
vient entre défoncer en fait ça les
films d'horreur the path comme scream
quoi le mec il arrive et ils te tuent
qu'enfin la scène là c'est pas ce crime
assez valentina goulinat elle est d'une
tête quoi du match et elle gagne elle
gagne tous les matches par la soudaine à
si elle gagne d'aider celles là
championnat c'est la finale voix juste
et bien donc du coup c'est un peu c'est
un peu la patronne du game la faire
attention gros du coup c'est encore bien
pour les blancs dans cette histoire
colonnes d oui on plaît alors toujours
la zone l'inventeur de ballack non mais
c'est vrai qu'elle a toujours mieux j'ai
cadre pourquoi pas réfléchir pendant que
cette chute ou à thème poêlée de comics
sur internet pour y nommer franchement
elle est vraiment impressionnante non
non j'ai vingt pièces mais ses proches
elle pouvait pas non mais non niveau
maintenant mais là je crois qu'elle fait
un peu n'importe quoi on parle peu et
jour jusqu'à dégager 500 vont fléchir
mais c'est son style non là ça va mais
voilà maintenant non mais pourquoi elle
est mal peut pas prendre sur trois ans
et s'est trouvée pour moi j'ai pas
compris
oui mais l'influent de pluzz donc ouais
mais c'est pas forcément une finale si
simple à gagner non non non
mais peut-être des quêtes des trois déjà
oui vous êtes cavaliers 5 a value cette
non là je suis saoul pour jouer ou pas
je sais pas c'est vrai qu'on nous
rappelle qu'elle avait failli faire nul
qu'on
trg nakamura en lente y'a pas à
gibraltar
il ya deux ans marc hé ouais non
vraiment je me rappelle pas ce que je
fais équipe pro de chez style je vous ai
dis heureusement que c'est pas tomber le
jour où elle joue en pro de chasse ligue
avec nous parce que sinon la partie
allait durer huit heures avait fini par
perdre mais là elle va faire à trois et
on prend des cinq mutuelles regarde il
lui reste 2 minutes 36 hockey lah pas
très bien joué mais elle joue tout tempo
en fait elle te met la pression
je sais pas j'aime pas trop les lettres
lui confèrent les gens je me sens à
réfléchir mais et le bus à 8 est bien
quoi elle suit les conseils elles
évitent à tout bien et je n'ai pas
toujours bien mais c'est pas grave
bon elle va avoir un pion moi mais ça va
tenir sa batterie niary tally continue à
jouer tempo quoi qu'il en soit elle s'en
fout je rappelle que maïté super peur
honte avait joué contre marc andrieu
passé nucléaire dangereux marc trouve
rien n'avait pas y avait toujours tempo
vraiment 15 + 2 avait fait la partie
tempo allait finir à 14 minutes je crois
fort que tout et émana capable de faire
quelques ennemis qui masque en même
temps mais là je suis pas sûr elle
aurait peut-être pu et citoyen je suis
pas à l'origine de mètres la tour en a
cinq j'aimerais bien voir c'est tout un
peu plus loin
dans les secondes est réellement faire
ou hqe être tombé 4 ok sur la fête et kg
6 peut-être et avait pas le temps de
faire h 4 h 5
mais c'est tout je comprends pas qu'on
regarderait voilà je crois qu'ils ont
gardé la tour proche du roi en fait ces
attaques et yao qu'elle peut perdre le
tour parce qu'il ya des fourchettes de
fois bah oui pas eu tour ça se met loin
n'ont normalement mais bon ouais bah
après la remise loin mais il m'a fait
peur et attend elle peut pas 123 la
réunion je crois qu'il n'a pas vu elle a
juste pas vu un léger simple lalalala
elle craque
là elle craque un peu qui apaise quatre
là je voulais récupérer vii
mais le pion h il est dangereux
maintenant mais je pense qu'elle a juste
complètement craqué et elle récupère tf
sept ans quand j'ai cette web bien joué
à mais ouais ça oui le lion a défendu
son avis aussi à monsieur carl f 4
michel berger à hohrod as assez bien
joué mais est-ce qu'elle va mener sa
quête jours il arrive à une caténaire
concernés ouais non ça va gagner oui
parfois encore la gagne et quand même l
58 5 euros à 4 kg 3 le plein et semble
pas très compliqué mais bon ouais je
capte mais nationalement on est venu à j
ok ça j'aurais pas fait d'enlever la
tour à tour 6 3 ok elle veut monter à
voir par là mais ok encore les échecs
ici oui et en invitant à john lennon
pages d avoir des pions aux besoins
auxquels a droit tous gagnants de toute
façon tu aurais enfin au coin et aux
roches quatre noms et cesse annoncée
papa tu es encore un pion attention aux
caisses à gagner mais là c'est au point
f2 et j'ai trois échecs voile revient à
deux points
ça reste ça reste ça reste serré comme
match à une petite troupe offs qui prend
2 g ça s'est passé c'est plutôt bien je
trouve de prendre de g tu ramènes un pur
au centre en fait je joue ça avec les
blancs donc je connais un petit peu mais
je pense qu'il faut faire c'est 4 ici ce
que j'allais dire est ok c'est en fait
avant je pensais que c'était vraiment
bien pour les noir et en fait c'est
genre pas clair
pardon tu prends du cavalier de mémoire
qui est si tu prends du pillon je me
suis déjà retrouvé à perdre ce options
on te fait aussi son te prend de fait
s'appelle toujours dangereux
en fait tu vas tu peux te retrouver tu
avec le pion isolé comme ça après le
point d'être bon mais peut-être que dans
cet entre-deux coup là ça va on va dire
bonjour à laurent qui est dans le chat
qui est un habitué
mais tu vois ça tu alors entier qui
avaient regardé le match goût nina
contre kosteniuk et lui s'est arrêté il
pensait kosteniuk avait gagné 1
oui c'était le maintien
ouais j'ai essayé de garder la fin
c'était un beau match
ouais c'était vraiment kosteniuk elle
joue vraiment bien je trouve
ben oui elle est très très dangereux
très très dangereuse et je rappelle
avoir vu jacques je crois que j'ai déjà
vu battre cramique en partie réelle en
blitz
oui je pense un peu sale aime bien on
jouerait de plus de ces deux journées
sur internet
j'étais très surpris que vanina
valentina gagne mais duel allait
impressionnante quand même valentina
toi-même même si elle fait des erreurs
mais malgré tous ses défauts c'est quand
même un ce qu'elle fait c'est quand même
fort parce qu'elle joue tout tempo elle
te mets une pression sur trois heures et
demie c'est quand même impressionnant
non mais j'ai compris qu'ils avaient été
un beau fin demain en finale j'ai un
gros fan de valentina franchement je
suis impressionné j'ai compris
franchement je suis impressionné non
mais tu vois c'est beau tu as de jouer
vite comme ça mon âge
des fois c'est trop vite il me semble
oui je sais elle joue vite et pas très
bien des fois mais elle vous vite quoi
quant au blitz un enfant mais je vais
vite et bien
mathias et d'expression sata plus
finalement bon alors là du coup regarde
elle se rapproche elle se rapproche avec
du cavalier f 4 m des torrents h8 la
tour en g8 est attaqué c'est vraiment
une variante pour le jouer avec les
blancs je déteste jouer cette variante
avec les blancs il pourquoi nous parce
que j'ai pas le répertoire mais bon il
faut faut contacter matière noire net de
la liaison mais j' en ai parlé de il
faut que je prenne des cours mans
vraiment on en a parlé plusieurs fois
que vous me donnez des cours ouais il va
me faire progresser de fou à et les
bombes il est bon mathieu il est très
bon donc d'un mètre
tu pense pas qu'elles veulent échanger
les dames je pense qu'elle veut dames et
g4 en fait
mes côtés elle s'en sort pas mal
finalement avec les blancs écoutes elles
d'armes le fou elle fait un peu son camp
va peut-être surprend même de la tour
d'ivoire et même avec le pion c'est
maintenant j'en sais d'eux était jouable
mais en fait oui finalement tuant change
d'avis comme de chemise les blancs sont
bien quand même une meilleure structure
de pions le h4 est ce que ça peut être
parce que je veux faire tu auras 7 est
bon je suis en classe pour moi c'est ma
baignoire ou allez-vous être non non non
les blanc domine c'est pas ça la vie de
là pour valentina non clairement
clairement il y n'a repris le a repris
les choses en main et il va falloir des
ventes et se battre à fond mon roi fuite
je pense bien jouer il faut empêcher
thor 07 h namco relief cap maman et à
tatouer le pion des 5
qu'est-ce qu'on peut être tentée
d'insister sûr ton idée en font des six
mais pour essayer de faire à 5 tours 7
et cette fois ci en plus combiné avec mr
je sais pas on est en train de se passer
une bonne chose
moi j'ai pensé ce projet 3 aussi pour
empêcher de communiquer plus
prophylactique mais après apprécié le
cavalier prise de poids de seulement 5,5
qu'elle empêche charmant angers 3 2 juin
[Musique]
on ne peut pas faire un nom j'ai pensé à
tour ses six pour autant corruption pas
idiot
c'est un jeu de manoeuvre la intéressant
pas mal et j'ai l'impression que
valentine en train de revenir un peu
dans la partie même si ça reste dur mais
là je pense faut trouver un bon coup
avec les noirs ce n'est pas forcément
facile bâtiment weekly elle encore 10
secondes c'est pas possible elle ce même
à l'otan depuis le début de la
compétition ça c est trop dur de jouer
avec elle je suis un contournement par e
mail a battu à labatut l'agglo et à
labatut et à labatut et arica comme ça
c'est l'agglo belle joueuse en plus un à
wil attenant elle est très très forte
honnêtement j'étais très surprise quand
j'ai vu le résultat
j'ai pensé que leur nombre à bagnères de
tendre elle est favorite après un prêt
dont elle avait les candidats aussi qui
était plus une priorité peut-être et
donc habilement paris j'étais peut-être
en plein stage ou alors c'est ce qui se
passe se passe beaucoup de choses
peut-être cavaliers 6 pour essayer de
marquer tromper 3 pourquoi pas mais
regarde regarde regarde au non c'est pas
possible c'est pas possible non mais ok
mais tu peux pas tomber à chaque fois
non c'est juste
on entre elles font qu'un jour plus vite
mais je sais c'est marrant ça va bien
mal
non mais c'est la deuxième échec dans
les deux premiers matches elle n'a pas
perdu une fois elle n'a pas perdu une
fois comme ça c'est comme si en fait
elle arrivait pas comme valentina joue
plus vite que les autres
oui oui oui elle réussit pas à résister
à sa vitesse elle était mal autant
contre les autres mais les autres je
vais pas aussi vite que valentina mais
bon faut peut-être qu'elle accélère un
peu la cadence parce que je pense
qu'elle pourrait jouer un peu plus vite
en milieu de jeu parce que oui bon
face à elle c'est pas ça je sais pas je
suis passé à l'ombre et une petite pirc
et ça va faire quoi ça va pousser
infondée à 4 à 5 des quatre pour prendre
de l'espace lambé 3d un doublé sur la
condamner l'un des dessins je comprends
elle veut faire à 5 à 4 pourquoi donc on
le dit dans le chat que dany lyon est
juste plus forte stratégiquement est
techniquement possible mais elle s est
un jeu aussi
mais je sais pas ce qu'elle avait gagné
les qualifications que tu avais pas pu
jouer d'ailleurs si je jouais tu vas
jouer des crozes ces chèques
j'ai fait un tournoi à bordeaux un tour
rapide et après nous ce soir j'ai décidé
de juste en main de la qualification
donc première portée je fais mal nulle
et après je perds trois parties
d'affilée et a quitté pour moi j'ai
évité le tournoi c'était mais la cadence
30 le sang c'est un peu dur pour moi
parce que je joue pas beaucoup ça
internet
et quand je joue je fais trop plus de ça
fait une grosse différence en ferait
pour moi oui
l'ours conséquence je suis un peu trop
20 pour les cours donc je tombe aussi
non mais c'est vraiment une vraie
différence qu'en fait 3 + 2 tu peux te
mettre mal autant mais 3% sur internet
en fait c'était mal c'est très difficile
un plus c'est pourquoi je sais pas bon
duo
devant il ya des joueurs qui jouent les
gens soient internet ils sont bons pour
pré mauvais pour les coûts vite moi je
suis parce que par exemple karine car il
m'a d'ailleurs je veux tu as porté
confrères pour kevin c'est pas normal de
jouer
après je ne me fais pas ça voilà ils
m'ont tous les boutons non mais c'est
pas j'aime pas ça avoir une autre non
c'est un choix mais je trouve ça paraît
donc plus jeunes un peu trop après j'ai
dit que je me mêle à ces termes vous
devez le temps je sais je sais je l'aï
un peu trop le nom mais après je les
trouve sur le tient tous les ans que je
sais comme icare ou a été vaguement
sortirait dit que j'étais encore très
loin d'hikaru oui mais non ça n'a pas
fait rire du nom elle est contente et je
peux te dire qu'on l'a fait tellement de
fois que j'en ai marre
il y en a marre c'est vrai que sur
internet ça se fait beaucoup
du coup va faire tour déjoué mathieu m'a
écrit officiel était trop forte est ce
que tu as écrit j'avais écrit que carey
n'a été pas qu'on sorte oui c'est
marrant parce que comme j'étais obligé
avec m du coup du coup tu vas un peu
défendu quand même je n'ai jamais dit
que j'étais un mec sympa c'est bizarre
que tu fais ça je comprends pas il est
sympa vous en faites pas trop
non mais je pense qu'on l'avait fait on
honnêtement l'avais fait juste avant ou
trois parties avant ça m'avait soul est
en fête du coup je me suis dit en a
marre qu'on me le fais je vais le faire
aussi mais pas remplies car oui il le
fait à chaque fois ça ouais c'est
bizarre j'étais pas pour moi c'est pas
normal
mais après une heure autour de 200
internet moi je suis le jeu différent
c'est le conseil que j'aime pas trop
dans ses différents mais comme pour la
planète joue pas mal hein sur internet
pardon elle joue bien karina pour la
peine
oui oui j'ai peint célèbre puisque 2006
mais j'aimerais déjà 25 80 quand elle
jouait vraiment mieux que c'était lola
en fait ouais
à part un pas contraire elle est bien
sûr internet et joue bien elle joue en
général sans rajout de temps au moins
c'est juste un souci je déteste ça et
les boulettes
par exemple je pense au moins c'est pas
les échecs juste et j'ai toutes les
pistes porto est toujours sur le banc
ouais bah c'est un peu ça oui il ya
gentilhomme ça donc c'est déjà beaucoup
peut-être je faisais moi c'est un autre
jeu en fait oui alors cette position à
moi j'aime bien de fois j'ai trois ici
mais faut 6 et les panneaux bleus moi
j'aime bien les noirs écoute moi j'aime
bien les blancs vous prendre des quêtes
et tous les trois mois je ne prononcerai
pas sur les menaces des blancs je ne je
ne donne pas de conseils aux ennemis 1
ok je ne dirai pas ce qu'on veut de
cette engeance par ailleurs en fait je
sais pas ah mais c'est pour ça et elle l
affaire bras g8
non elle a empêché oui mais c'est vrai
que l a pris quand même comment lui
demander si elle pouvait faire f4
honnêtement mais c'est changer un simple
tellement ça échange juste d'un prendra
prend tôt on mangeait pas de neige
j'ai pensé que tu dois je vais pas dire
en fait j'ai pas trouvé parce que je me
disais louer.fr être quatre mois juste
ont trois ou quatre noms ouais donc
quelqu'un sa manche pas aimer tour des 3
j'ai pensé la tour prend à y avons
croisé ce 10 mai s'est investie
peut-être ou non là ça fait là ça fait
une grosse différence
la démente et franchement franchement
d'un v6
c'est en fait voir si c'est pas bon
valentine elle fait tout le temps la
même tête comme quoi qu'il se passe que
tu filmes d'amandine c'est la même tête
ça n'a rien à faire mais on sait que
c'est pas c'est pas mal hein ne montre
pas des inventions être comme la dette
est pas un visage
c'est simple comme dans game of thrones
j'ai passé à regarder le game of thrones
j'ai parlé mardi à une personne qui a
réussi à tous les visages du monde fait
à laisser leur verse à la 15 villages
bon du coup ça fait plus 4 et j'ai du
mal à voir comment il yn'a pourrait
revenir dans la partie
sauf si voilà 10 nanterre la connexion
ça suffit a lancé par la connexion miss
mise à part perte de connexion bull est
franchement je vois pas dans quel monde
elle elle revient à leur revient dans le
match
mouais
donc dans le set est peut-être en plein
en complément ou pas non c'est pas vrai
car les cinq clients et tam a été prise
en main est de jouer juste ah ouais ben
kay ap cinq dames 1 ça me paraît juste
très fort mais tu vois là par exemple je
pense qu'elle vous parle tu vois c'est
le genre de moment elle pourrait jouer
un peu plus vite atteint pourquoi le jeu
beau corps et âme simple raison qu'elles
vont insister sur le fait qu'elle veut
que trouver le truc mais je pense pas
que ce soit mais elle joue pareil de ton
rappelle un parti à nantes mais aussi
pour f 5 g 6 x 3 1
c'est de là que relève sans que c'était
vraiment tentant mais après peut-être un
peu des armées sirpa mer
dames 1 ouais peut-être je sais pas la
machine ne sais pas trop mais moi je
veux quand ils sont bons alors à temps
et les des quatre points et froid tout à
l'heure elle n'a pas fait ouais mais je
pense pas que ce soit très bon marché
ouais j'ai l'impression qu'on a
tellement peu d'activités peut-être
cavailles cavaliers au catch c'est pas
pour essayer de joie moi quand valeo 4
après vous et attention des fois des
fonds non mais attends que cavaler
auquel il faut prendre un core i5 os
quelques les voilà que c'était mort en
fait un travail est comprise donc mais
la dame n'a pauvres de bangkok on tape
la donne ouais non non ça n'est pas du
tout dans ses systèmes son nom est là là
là c'est un massage las un massage
arménien la cua
les malinois a nommé arménienne tu vas
tu dises un massage arménien je ne veux
pas été apprécié on s'est passé c'est
que moi qui l'a dit en fait
adacore donc je n'a plus que tu peux
dire l'expression les gens ne la
connaîtrons pas non plus certes fait
quand même très à portion d'expression
que tu apprends sur cette chaîne ça peut
être des expressions qui n'existe pas en
réalité
ouais mais là on fait des cartes tu
comprends pas vains là je comprends et
en fait c'est parti je comprends rien
fait c'est normal de ne pas échanger des
balles à blanc
quelque chose sur le roi bah ouais parce
que la bonté ya pions isolé en d5 mes
options b4 aussi fin et qui ont pour
dessein qu'il est bien défendue g
oui tout à fait en aval et aussi donc il
est bien de foot ok ça c'est possible
ouais mais je pense honnêtement je tiens
à 6 tours b6 eu accès à l eau ne pas
jouer d'élèves peut-être cause de b5
ouais donc alors je la trouvais six
prochains gysi ce qu'on valait 1 6 on
est encore allergies se délecte h5 que
le calme ne s'est pas la démonter je
crois que ça se passe dans la tête
vraiment pas ce qu'il y avait il y avait
vraiment du jeu d'attaqué elle n'a pas
osé un ouais je ne comprend pas c'est
même un elle a juste rien ici là
peut-être cavalli aussi ses cavaliers en
chine
j'ai les deux fous voulaient refaire
guerre george schultz peur des pillages
à certains oaxaca lieu de france mkv f5
ça évite et gsea ces trucs week-end sur
foot des trois français va tout juste
tout échanger faire fouassin ok là y'a
pas genre prises des 4 es tu peux jamais
prendre de la tour adria four de toute
façon tu peux te prendre des quatre
perdre le pion des cinq essais nul quand
même bon on ne va pas faire exprès mais
un point crise
ttc 5,4 maintenant oui les caraïbes
car les dégâts de vous envoyer 5
je peux aussi jouer pour ces 8 oui il ya
plein de coups continuent hélas les
blancs ont laissé passer leur chance
oui belkouch c'est très bizarre mais je
ne sais pas c'est aussi ne pas indiquer
sa part confère à l'accord si je sais
qu'on panique mais non mais tu sais
c'est vraiment je le répète mais quand
koke si c'est peut-être bien jouer ici
steve et quatrième rangs des cinq des
six comme l'un des quatre cavaliers des
5 voilà réussi à obtenir le pion mais
elle a plus de temps comme des week-ends
non mais ça voilà à l'avancé pour de bon
là ça va aller enfin ce n'est peut-être
pas pour gagner mais je leur parle
actuelle changé
ok tu peux te dis faut skier au souk
manche 82,7 fait rage et 6h 5,3 g 7
inchangé de cavaliers qui passe et faire
nul au kg 5
amélie 5 0 lourd je fais g5 et il
arrivera sur f5 un jour peut-être même
pas rien comment peut-être par g3
je tends 4l faut pas pousser à 4 j'en ai
encore les ajouts et peut-être qu'un
touché quatre fois ouais ok mais
regardez elle reprend beaucoup de temps
à mes ailes d'un garçon en chine
maintenant elle va perdre sur h6 mais
bon il va perdre sur la piste ok là
c'est fini
non mais ma fille de 7 ans qu'elle est
encore moins longtemps mais comment tu
es mais elle va jamais attaqué f2 là je
passe quelques jets contre wayne ont
assez mais j'ai comme on sent qu'elle
qu'en soit la nature y parvenir la spa
possible avec les noirs elle peut pas
sauver sa kosteniuk d'ailleurs elle a
joué les positions jusqu'à jusqu'à la
mort est incroyable elle joue très
longtemps quand elle est mal à
l'abandonnent pas long mais je suis le
conseil personne n'a jamais gagné une
partie en abandonnant je pense c'est
très bon conseil c'est génial je vois tu
vas être ce soir tu vas voir réfléchir à
tous ces bons conseils gagné une partie
avec des martyrs en abandonnant attend
ça c'est pas il serait bien mouvement
pour sa cave et il m'a bien joué et
jouent très bien ce final oui c'était
complètement cogné un juge et je trouve
qu'elle était précise quand même
ouais elle est bien revenu il reste 23
minutes ont trois plus un elle revient à
3 points
écoute
c'est plutôt plutôt intéressant pour
elle oui n'attendait pas c'est plus
intéressant c'est un lieu ouais ouais
non ça elle recolle au bon moment parce
que si elle tombait à - 5 - si je pense
que c'était c'était fini mais là on
revient à trois points
elle boit elle se bat bien et j'aime
bien les noirs cette fois ci c'est tout
simple ouais et coûtent le match est
peut-être en train de va pas d'y
retourner mais nina qui semble être un
peu mieux quand même sur ses trois plus
sympa ce que regarde elle a perdu deux
parties en tombant et ses deux parties
où elle était bien ouais donc il
pourrait vraiment s'il n'y avait pas eu
ces deux coups du sort
elle pourrait elle pourrait être pour
être quasiment à égalité
ouais mais tu te rappelles au début
c'était valentina qu'il était devenu
c'est vrai que ça s'équilibre un petit
peu mais sur le 3 + 1 c'est plutôt et
lina qui domine c'est marrant hein c'est
pas forcément le score reflète pas
forcément ce qu'on voit je ne suis pas
quelqu'un de force et de jouer plus vite
parce que deux parties hautes de 40 ans
ça fait mal là c'est trop tôt par elle
même bien j'ai déjà c'est pas facile de
quand tu m'aimes ans elle a fait ça dans
les deux premiers matchs bessaih quand
tu joues contre des adversaires qui sont
un poil plus fort que toi c'est parce
qu'elle a eu des mauvaises positions
quand même un du cul c'est beaucoup plus
difficile mais l'a finalement je veux
que ça se passe pas mal pour les blancs
ils ont mis tous les pions sur noir ça
me paraît
ça paraît quand même un peu mieux mais
après comment progresser avec les blancs
c'est vrai que le foot rend pas si ce
n'est pas terrible elle va essayer de
jouer peut-être avec g4 est ce que tu en
penses
bonjour est ce qu'ils vont juger 400 mhz
en même temps aux samares jamais 5 ça
fait quand même un peu peur mais sans
prise et enfin j'ai fait un temps fou
ouais ça que quatre pas idiot et j'aime
bien peut-être fait changer d'avis mais
après taterf sens qui c'était non mais
oh 5 à 4 c je n'ai pas à me oui ça ne
risquait même et là trop c'est trop et
thurau on va voir oui faut bessin écoute
j'aurais vraiment non mais je pense que
là nord sont déjà pas mal et c'est très
bizarre ce qu'elle est venue
entreprendre à l aller les dames vanina
elle est venue un peu faire des choses
moi je pensais qu'elle reçoit l'autre
sur le bras ya peut-être fouquet tourbe
ici sur youtube ici c'est très bien mais
te voit donc comme moi j'invite
maintenant lna wen a accéléré et manon c
est valide un qui a du mal à jouer vite
du coup quoi faire bref on est bon je
crois j'apprends je prends pas je
plongerai font des cinq ans lui
appartient de peut-être moi je prendrais
je me dirais que la sécurité du roi
blanc est pas top mais bon peut-être que
j'ai tort aux contres attend là je
comprends rien à à petit on prend et
adam g 4 et puis on prend là il ya
peut-être un truc avec tour des 8es mais
bon elle a raison d'appeler qu'adam g 6
et a tellement qui ont passé ouais elle
ne risque pas de 45 non
quand j'ai deux mois elle va mettre nous
faut sur détroit et le reprend la tour
ouais non mais elle est obligée de faire
d'alger 4 maintenant toute façon mais
n'ont pas signé de connexion à l'afld et
am3 et finalement je veux pas jouer la
finale
non mais c'est n'importe quoi non mais
elle fait n'importe quoi je sais pas non
mais c'est incroyable elle s'est mis à
jouer n'importe comment
vous êtes fous des 5 parce que tu auras
de te reprendre le pion sera carrément
tour est un prisme bassiste rob et 5
est-ce que ça va apparemment je gâche
rien vous pouvez cinq tours b 4 à 1
oui c'est peut-être pas si simple mais
là je vous besoin quand même mais dans
tous les cas on peut prendre surtout en
ont et a donné la qualité encore et
c'est pour ça que je comprends pas fou
des 2 faesch comprend rien fait non mais
juste et elle fait n'importe quoi elle
donne des pions un agent ou non oui si
tu joues à cannes mais sans danger car
est ok main sur f3 et le retour à deux
tours v2 en fait et tu vas te faire
ouais non c'est quasiment abandon dans
cette position oui pas beaucoup trou
cette tour à 4 c
adam ne bouge plus haut dans d'autres
des gaz ne bouge pas horrible torcéen
peut-être je sais pas en jeu 4 juste
pour faire un coup dans ces terrifiants
et elle est belle et mal elle est mal
connectés c'est le match en train de
tourner démontée oui c'est intéressant
elena est là une minute et elle fait
bien a ajouté mme peau surtout surtout
avoir l'indiana qui joue mal mais hélas
tout proche
alors il nous faut être prêt sur l'écran
croître on échange on mettra le faut ça
va te faire - et elle m'apprend non mais
je sais pas si je tue phares dans les
lans et c'est fini je pense que l'on
prend est ok peut-être dame prend pour
des crèmes et aref de damages de
maintenant c'est fini
ok rien met on a tenté d'aller ouais bon
et ça revient à deux points
c'est ça recolle non mais je suis
contente parce que j'aime bien quand
c'est un vieux et plus intéressant alors
tarder c'est nord qui nous dit là ça
s'inscrit dans la personnalité de vanina
quand elle est en mauvaise posture elle
a tendance à arrêter de chercher le coup
le plus précis pour plutôt chercher des
erreurs à faire faire à son adversaire
en gros il dit que
ouais que quand elle est mal elle va
juste cherché à placer un ou deux petits
pièges et puis c'est tout quoi elle
arrête de réfléchir objectivement faux
et donc vanina pas une autre difficulté
la oak est pourtant là cette ouverture
j'ai l'impression que ça se passe plutôt
bien elle menace cavaliers b4 au passage
à tours qui varie vend ses 8
ça ressemble plus aux positions qui nous
plaisait de tout à l'heure des montées
oui ça ressemble plus à ce qu'on aime
ouais je sais pas d'où cette ouverture
encore parce que il ne me semble pas que
elle a posé des problèmes financiers
non elle s'est fait poser des problèmes
oui mais tu vas même la regarde sur des
princes et saint qu'elle aurait pu faire
qui a et b cas peut-être intermédiaire
ah oui mais elle a fait le tempo mais
français 5
après je sais pas ce qui est des cas
c'était bon pas mais j'aurai la même pas
elles marchent vraiment commencé ses
rangs une surfeuse en fait c'est sur les
vagues quoi mais là pas retirée avant si
un jour aucun impôt et après elle
réfléchit mais ça marche pas comme ça
en juin que tu dois être sûr que ça
marche parce que si nos parcs direct
allez c'est marrant écoute c'est
vraiment étonnant
il est un style elle joue toujours comme
ça et des fois ça marche très bien
oui par contre quand ça marche ça doit
être terrifiant pour l'adversaire
ouais parce qu'en fait tu prends tout
tempo et a pas le temps de réagir
ouais ça nous fait perdre parce que elle
joue avec la confiance même les mots des
couches ou un dut colorature entoure ces
dons c'est aussi vite a sûrement faire
pouët 5ème bonne personne tant que cfo
est faisable
white ra ça c'est sûr ça elena est ce
que votre corps et le corps déjà trois
aides alors ça fait pas marrer c'est la
grosse des connexions je crois à mouassa
reconnecte mai
elle souffre vraiment sa connexion la
pauvre donc à 6 ou l'instant donc d'être
cavaliers ou deux qui est chez 3com tout
à leurs cavaliers à 4 oui c'est typique
l'hapoel 5 c'est celle à ses écrits on a
vu alors fois je sais tout il faut
achète bien joué d'ailleurs
oui parce que le roi se rachète âpre
entre l'info sont des deux mois c est la
fois f5 voilà elle a fait son truc
elle menace reprend 17 et une
chorégraphe est simple tout simplement
ouais supprime le défenseur du bien fait
parce que je ne vois pas comment
défendre le clan d'ailleurs c'est comme
ça qu'à hollywood
oui tu as raison parce que les planches
de dessins qu'il est un prix aussi après
0,6 bon elle fait cavalier 5 avec la
même idée sur karaj et franck à ypres en
qui les français 5 pour ces huit
j'imagine mais quatre mais non il n'ya
pas tour celui-ci halfway 5
oui je fus f5 est vraiment faut en fait
c'est génial d'approché prochaines
parties donc que tu joues avec les pions
pour nom tu vas y penser à ce faux f5
c'est sûr ah ouais elle a déjà deux
derniers hommes qui n'ont hélas
peut-être qu'ils avaient des 3es à mais
maintenant il ya un pion sur trois mais
on s'y sent prise il va y avoir tu vois
peut-être m des dames des quatre qui
vont arriver que je pense que ça va
encore faire un point pour elin ah oui
elle elle est beaucoup mieux en entier
ivo karlovic cueillis dans le tchad
j'aimerais voir daniel yon gagner car on
aura au moins une chance de voir une
célébration ou un sourire marans
c'est vrai que 10 et valentina qui gagne
à la valentine à les plus connectés à la
plus de connexions à la plus rien un
mince mais je suis vraiment inquiet pour
elle parce que j'ai l'impression qu'elle
est de plus en plus déconnectés tu as vu
quand je regarde ronan regarder alan
actrice sur son visage
la tare expression elle est un peu
désespéré n'en regarde j'ai l'impression
que parmi elles un peu plus loin que la
connexion ça la sallaz désespère un peu
ça c'est dommage que ça joue là dessus
pas que ça se joue là dessus après celle
ci vous pas que la fumée notamment là
dessus ouais elle a tragiquement mal
barré je plainds que ça voilà mon avis
elle aurait tout jouer ben tu as vu
quand elle avoue joueront ensuite elle a
déjà mis sept ou huit secondes alors que
c'était jusque là oui c'est vrai pas
comprendre ce qui se passe sans problème
vient de voir alex perd ça dit que quand
elle valait fait visage qu'elle a
sûrement vu tout le temps qu'elle avait
perdue avait dû se rendre compte des
jouets tempo ym resterai secondes
mesdames g5 tu vois elle a quand même
réussi malgré la position difficile à
poser des petits problèmes
elle va faire quoi et cavaliers f3 vous
prend être 4 sûrement l'action prenait 3
peut-être juste un pion pro f 4 et d'un
refrain f 4g d'un match 5 menace mat
c'est bien joué ça j'ai trois trous
rien rien d'éternel d'apprendre qu'un 3e
séparés
cette année c'est probablement mieux
roger kahn a bien vu ouais et ça fait 7
8 écoute ça fait 3 3 parties d'affilée
pour une ida fou et valentina qui va
devoir arrêter l'hémorragie et sec
l'enlaçant un peu nan mais franchement
là voilà on voit on voit les pressions
sur son visage honnêtement web triste
ouais elle a l'air complètement perdu la
pauvre allez c'est dur c'est bien la
pose de la première manche il faut
qu'elle se ressaisisse 17 parties telles
qu'elles mettent un peu ses problèmes de
connexion derrière et qu'elle réussisse
à ce son courage elle mène encore au
score 1-1 démente et elle mène d'un
point et le moule est magnifique elle
pour m
après parfois elle est dans un hôtel la
connexion ça peut être un peu inattendu
s'est il suffit que ce soit lors du
dîner dans son hôtel ou quoi les gens
partent et saint denis revient quoi
ouais donc on peut alors que la
connexion marche très bien dans les
autres c'est pas facile d'aller dans les
hôtels toi qui voyagent beaucoup
d'ailleurs quand tu vas dans des pays un
peu un peu difficile ça se passe comment
ça dépend ça veut rien dire par mkg
maire de montmagny il n'ya jamais
d'internet quand je fais la nuit romaine
est à jamais dans l'internet dans la
chambre ça me rend folle et tu voyages à
peu près combien de fois par an pour
d'étourneaux des lic suis pas dit a pu
quantifier mais tu pars combien de fois
de chez toi mon ami et moi n'est pas
rien
il ya des toilettes la période quand je
fais quelques de trois tournois
d'affilée
c'est surtout en automne parce que je
sais pas pourquoi ils viennent de mettre
plein de tourner en automne
officiel comment les européens de la
coupe d'europe
et tout comme ça à l'été jouant bien
évidemment parce qu'en général les gens
y joue au contraire plus de tournois ni
té parce qu'ils ont plus de temps il ya
pas mal d'opel mais moi je pop ou par
exemple ils jouent pas là un autre
insecte en bouche tu vas pas jouer les
championnats de france à chartres où
quoi as tu peux tu as pas encore le
passeport que non cette bientôt je sais
pas on verra
c'est pas facile mais à mais du coup
être tu peux pas tu peux pas encore donc
du coup tu joues les olympiens avec la
lituanie
oui elle est toujours première échiquier
donc ouais ok et dont les noms et donc
tu fais beaucoup de beaucoup de tournois
dans l'année et à quels sont les pays
les plus j'ai pas exotique que tu es
plus visité avec les échecs
peut-être que la nouvelle zélande et
l'australie
voilà ça tu recommandes pardon tu
recommande d'aller visiter
ah oui tu étais et j'ai beaucoup aimé
surtout l'inde zélande et on a fait un
point là bas avec mathieu est pré
installé en australie
donc c'était vraiment très intéressant
tu sais pas si je peux encore faire un
voyage la voie d'un mali parce qu'ils
sont vraiment très très lent
en quatre heures d'avion assez loin oui
c'est très long mais bon ça vaut le coup
après je suis allé en chine argentine
argentine l'arabie saudite les pays
comme ça tu avais joué les championnats
du monde de rapides et depuis en arabie
saoudite
c'est ça et après je suis nulle cette
année un marx pour faire un tournoi de
rapides mais il n'était pas je sais pas
vous mais n'y avait pas beaucoup
d'étrangers qui sont venus
je sais pas si j'ai manqué de publicité
ou juste les gens ont peur d'y aller
mais les prix étaient très bon là-bas
mais donc les conditions de jeu et le
teil peut-être eh bien oui je comprends
que l'arrivée sur dix ça fait un peu
peur oui il
ils font les efforts pour améliorer les
images les situer l'orme à geler ce sont
des chèques aussi ont protesté et
demandé qu'on sait comment faire pour
pour entraîner les enfants et qu'il faut
inviter les entraîneurs donc j'ai
l'impression qu'ils ont envie de de
l'élimination des chèques
ouais ouais donc ça c'est bon match tout
est dit donc c'est ça c'est des beaux
voyages quoi oui c'est intéressant de
voir les comme ça parce que l'arabie
saudite en on
on pense toujours qu'il inviterait
bizarre
très fermé avec la loi très stricte
toi t'as pas ressenti ça en tant qu' en
tant qu' en tant que touriste en tout
cas enfin pas vraiment tourisme en tant
que sportive on va dire mais c'est
intéressant parce que quand je fais
quand je jouais à lille d après ce
tournoi un rail il s'était interrogé
t'es pas obligé de m me voyais par
exemple ah ouais tu n'es pas obligé non
non on n'était pas obligé d'en quoi
c'était pas peut-être une surprise pour
le champion du monde
une des conditions jeu j'imagine que les
étrangères ne porte pas le voile mais
juste pour un tournoi en herbe comme
j'ai fait un tour en 2 rapide
ils n'ont ils ont dit qu on peut juste
nous habiller habituellement oh non on
n'est pas obligé de mettre un voile
c'est quand même c'est quand même de
gros prouvé quoi oui exactement
n'importe quoi il faut les efforts c'est
cool c'est cool bref outre pendant qu'on
discutait de tout ça il n'a encore gagné
une partie au la vache c'est ouais c
c'est un peu la catastrophe à dallas
pour pour valentina qui vient
d'enchaîner un lacet qu'un ménage quatre
mamans qui vient d'enchaîner qui vient
d'enchaîner quatre défaites et lina qui
revient à 8 partout et il semble qu
yanina soit favorite du match en
maintenant à ce moment là en tout cas
oui elle a pris l'initiative donc et les
flocons fin et le plus complet peut-être
en saurons-nous parce que quand tout
commence à gagner importés après
d'autres cette demande d'énergie comme
ça alors après faut pas qu'elle retombe
dans ses travers dans ses défauts parce
que là il lui reste déjà 2 minutes 15
après sept coups donc à la dépense et 40
secondes pour pour l'ouverture et on
sait
des ventes et que c'était c'était un peu
son problème en début de match
d'utiliser trop belle tombe donc
seulement gagner il faut garder le même
rythme au total donc par contre je crois
que tu as b3g pas un match que les
revenus dans le chat et pourra il pourra
confirmer j'ai l'impression que c'était
vraiment cavaliers h4 le coup en fait
c'est mon répertoire avec les noirs donc
ça j'ai jamais vu et quand tu joues avec
ses 5 ça me paraît juste qu'il va y
avoir b6 et ça me rappelle les parties
d'un vieux match stany du 14 juillet
beaucoup de positions comme ça abc ce
qui arrive et e5 et c'est un peu la
catastrophe à la fois pour les blancs
ouais
premier match pour le titre elle doit
bouger la dame de fer
baker je pense oui l'opt et soeurs dame
des armées du coup l autre enfin
valenciennes va jouer avec eux cinq je
pense je pense que juste cinq noms me
viennent tourner tout cela fait il faut
bouger la large vainqueur 4 à ma liberté
6 ou 5 ça va aller très vite en et
valentina qui a dépensé que fin dix
secondes il ya aussi un peu leur
ajoutant mais elle a quasiment pas
réfléchi jusque là qu'elle peut faire
qu'il prend des deux fours en d3 aussi
mais bon pourquoi prendre ce fou emploi
je peux aussi lever 11,5 et je suis doit
prendre non ce que s'il ya eu 4 5 et 4
qui arrive au point quand il ya plein
d'enfants année donc c'est là ce sera la
dernière partie 1 des ventes et de 3 + 1
tu remarques que le temps passe de plus
en plus vite dans ses matches un prêt
après tu as l'impression que la première
heure et demie tu as et un peu tu dis
c'est un peu long et puis après tout
d'un coup c'est le match est fini le
temps des mets pas rendu compte donc f5
et wayne mais là c'est la cata démonter
arrêt maladie n'a elle a dans les poches
je pense que les clients je rejoins de
réfléchir je pense que c'est une partie
très importante pour valentina
psychologiquement pour pourra lire pour
aller prendre la pose a su avec une
meilleure meilleure humeur parce que là
sinon c'est cette fois chez 4 au 10 rue
du coup c'est parce que ça m'aide
voyager sans projet semaine c'est pas
mal quand même
tu fous g3 tu feras d'alger 5 cela sera
un peu de prendre
ouais je vous dis aussi fouache 4 1 qui
peut sur g3 tu prends juste we5 la
position de viol à l'ouverture a été
catastrophique mais f4 peut-être bien
joué à les chercheurs cherchent des
chances est un jeu je suis d'accord pour
essayer de compliquer un peu le jeu
parce que sinon juste te vas te faire
mentir la ya peut-être le fou qui arrive
en h4
quand même un de toute façon oui dans
tous les cas les ventes ont elles
atteint 4,8 à ger 3 peut-être non c'est
eux qu'on doit à merouana pourquoi bouge
je vais faire fief de rois princes 2-3
et d'un français 2 mai à dos les marchés
et 4 1 il
bon elle ne venait défendre le cumin
vous qu'elle vous faut trouver quelque
chose là c'est qu'il faut acheter g3
fort le truc avec force de sa marque le
pas j'arrive pas à le faire marcher
après tu préfères fief du roy et fin
d'un projet de fo prend 20 en fait et tu
rases et les deux tours et ça ça devait
marcher
ouais elle avec le cas on sera 4 ouais
moi que tu avais deux pions puissant je
pense
donc maintenant à commencer un jeu sur
l'autre côté les blancs sont construites
et encore presque en tout cas et le
cavalier ou trois forts un cavalier
bloqueurs c'est bon je préfère toujours
les noirs mais s est un peu moins
enclins à les voir son mieux mais est-ce
que c'est autant sa gamme a4
ça marche pas à grand chose l'orage et
d'autres où c'est bien joué tu prêt j'ai
un peu tout et tu te mets quoi peut-être
corlier si le collège saint pompon dans
métro peut-être très certainement et des
fois y'a qu'à valider cinq noms du
hockey et attend avec la dame a il peut
y avoir aussi des enfermements de fou un
jour un attention à mon nom mais
d'amener ses meilleurs jeunes cavaliers
il faut jouer sans répit mais là il ya
ça y'a pas damas quatre tombes et auquel
se donne dieu l'air ok j'ai pas du tout
aimé la séquence là pour grèce et bien
joué ça et on prend 2 way est
inacceptable et trop mal autant un port
et c'est sévère est là elle a bien joué
mais c'est le temps qui s'étend qui lui
a coûté donc là normalement la partie va
être annulé ça va être la pause s'est de
nouveau cinq minutes de pause reste une
demi heure exactement sera dans cinq
minutes a de suite démenti
je vais mettre la petite pub les mecs
et après on va y aller
[Musique]
les amis on est reparti pour le bullet
alors que tout le monde est en retard
démonter puisque le live n'est pas
vraiment partie mais c'est parti
tu vois la partie j'imagine ou référents
princesse mais c'est tragique au relais
les deux et donc et donc démente et
valentina valentina qui a un point
d'avancé
une demi heure de jeu tout va se jouer
toute la saison va se jouer dans les 30
minutes qui viennent démente et oui et
c'est il ya une petite somme d'argent je
crois qu'il ya cinq mille 5000 dollars
en jeu donc c'est quand même c'est quand
même une somme importante après je sais
pas si ces cas là au vainqueur ou à se
partager parce qu'il ya aussi un prix
pour pour le perdant mais il existe une
somme d'argent en jeu et donc sur trente
minutes c'est il ya un vrai enjeu au
delà du titre
non j'ai financiers et les noirs qui ont
un pion isolé dans cette ambition ou
fois aujourd'hui
alors en bullet est ce que tu vois à
voir le jeu dynamique qui sapent pas au
contraire être intéressant savent ce que
tu as envie d'attaquer donc le plus
isolés ici peut être une force même pour
pour le jeu de bullet ça fait le passé
l'argent mais là elle va à 3 way c'est
un piège les fous ces deux fous des 6 es
fou ses sept tours b 2e way ou tomber
deux c'est un piège rien croyable la
joueuse arménienne qui va se retrouver
finalement avec un pion de plus piège
contre pierre deux coups on l'a plus
toutes ont tous tombent là tout tombe là
c'est la catastrophe à la il ya le pur
et sain qui peut être en prise
la tour qui fait rien les pions de pouce
je pense qu'on va on va avoir une
égalisation dément tv5
non il ya eu
le attend cas là il y avait peut-être le
fou prend b5
elle n'a pas vu ça m'a pas l'air d'être
ton à 8 non mon gars tu me permets de
reprendre des saintes n'entreprend des
cinquièmes vous prendrez 5 brouillard va
peut-être tour à 8 du coût tour c8 et
tours et on prend tout reprend oui et on
prend des 5 à la fin ouais mais voilà
pas quoi ça sert noir fait tour à les
fous g6 faut tenter quelque chose pour
les blancs la difficile à la elle a raté
le coche à mon avis elle a raté sa
chance
valentina anker bien j mais non rien à
part dit ouais ça se sent ça se joue
autant prêt mais là ça ça devient dur
peut-être temps m6 dans le bon tempo
pour pour menacer un matin peu piégeur
et puis angers style bohème et non là là
tu peux tu peux rien faire je pense aux
juifs si c'est un moment ouvert
récemment non attendez vous à 2003 non
mais c'est hors de position
food et ça ça va ça va ça va ça ça ça
tient il y en a qui égalise 9 partout il
reste combien de temps il reste 26
minutes de jeu il reste à peu près sept
parties toutes les parties sont
importantes la connexion de valentina
qui s'est quand même bien remise démente
et c'est une bonne nouvelle on va on va
avoir un match et cette fois-ci et lina
qui réussit à jouer je pense qu'elle
souhaitait jouer tout à l'heure c'est la
vente avec cavalli b d2 peut être une
position un peu pénible à jouer avec les
noirs je sais pas si c'est son
répertoire mais là j'ai déjà
je trouve que la promotion des blancs et
je préfère par rapport à ce qu'on avait
avant
ouais l événement c'est bien développés
elle tient le centre les casses des cats
et car j'ai bien j'aime bien les blancs
donc est ce que tu penses fou prend h si
si si ça se tente
c'est un stand mais je sais pas si ce
temps un bon après ça peut être aussi
pour jouer sur le sur la pression 5 tu
nous avait lâché l'info démente et
qu'elle s'est entraîné en bullet et là
on le sent qu'ils ont prend dame prend
il ya la tour qui va pouvoir coulisses
et le cavalier angers 5 ou c'est pas
possible pour les mois des français
ouais c'est très bien joué d'ailleurs
elle prend pâle pour elle prend pas le
flux c'est quand même fou et 4 qui va
revenir largement tabou mais elle prend
quand même alors la chorale est un saint
c'est peut-être un peu un peu osé quand
même démonté un peu too much dans je ne
sais pas des simples peut-être non c'est
ok ça coince d'un match
ménard dames du relais dames point m6
donc il ya une vraie menace et me lasse
peut-être fou g6 aussi démontée regarde
ah oui même et bien souvent les freins
ni ça peut dresser ici sa menace autres
quelle preuve cet os x est oui
bon alors attends bas juste damage suite
d'appels si tu penses ouais ouais
au moins tu récupères la pièce et tu vas
rentrer dedans et c'est ce qu'elle fait
valentina qui est vraiment sur une
mauvaise phase et l'armenian la joueuse
armenian qui va reprendre le dessus
alors dams est à l échange les dames un
cours d un un peu étonnant après
beaucoup de pression la tour qui va
pousser les biens déjà 3h 4h par
matériellement
où on a un pion de plus pour les blancs
et les blancs qui vont envoyer mais mais
mais il peut encore se passer beaucoup
de choses dans cette partie regarde la
pendule quand même démente et 5 secondes
seulement pour elin a peut-être ainsi on
attend ses huit seul coup et pour l'un
son trou pour le moment ça tient
pourquoi la réplique à un cavalier
elle veut éviter elle a gagné autant
incroyable elle est tombée à la la elle
va dynamiser rapide mec mais elle a raté
sa chance non des montées au mans l
échange et les dames
oui mais c'est pas la bonne info quelle
que soit on comprend pas trop pourquoi
mais ses côtés mais ça mange pas
toujours comme ça finalement voulant
prendre moins de risques oui bah après
elle a un an de plus et pas illogique ce
qu'elle fait mais tombera stoxx rason le
chat qui dit qu'elle a aussi un problème
de connexion en non mais je pense qu'ils
troll je pense qu'ils trompent
à voir donc dam des deux cette petite
française est sur b4 et du cavalier à 4
toujours j'imagine qu'ils on prend des
cartons en d4 et là plutôt petit rock
n'ont pas tour des reptiles rock grand
roque on peut dans les parcs ou un autre
qui est un hymne à te faire c4 et des
cadres donc elle tient une nouvelle fois
ralenti naquit à un vrai avantage à la
pendule puisqu'il lui reste 52 secondes
contre 32 puis inviter les mains elle a
du mal mais tu vois il ya une grosse
différence et l'eau à ambühl être 2536
palin à 2270 ça pourrait ça pourrait
faire la différence dans ce match c'est
ça oui mais l'amour est il faut juste y
prenait beaucoup je pense pour ne pas
être emmené il faut jouer parce que
c'est une manière différente de jouer
est un mois je serai hyper vite
ouais mais c'est pas mal ce qu'elle a
fait tout à la frontale a fait caca et
profond prend 1,6 ou proches et athée
tout mais c'est vraiment après elle à
ces instants
de joueuse d'échecs normale entre
guillemets sont revenus tu as vanina
health et voilà enfin sais c'est un peu
primitif mais elle me regarda manche il
a mené trois fêtes truc c'est quelle
peur du mal à faire tout réussit à cause
de d4 peut-être elle veut préparer des
quatre cavaliers eu 4 1 2 peut-être vie
c'est par là j'ai l'impression que les
noirs sont en train de prendre le dessus
dans cette partie mais regarde le temps
explique au total 3 maintenant il faut
prendre les tours h3 et tu vois ça quant
à cette seconde à la pendule à bien
jouer autour des 800 ans maintenant que
je prends quand même non il faut prendre
si on prend un choc être bien joué ouais
mais tu as toujours à changer les vins
c'était fou et là elle a raison ouais
mais peut-être un poil précipiter sur
damas fuite
parce que là maintenant cette position
là est ce qu'elle va réussir
finalement est-ce que les blancs sont
pas mieux à cause de la pendule
justement g4 f5 la maison plus plus de
temps aussi regardent ailleurs qu'elle
va tout jouer tempo tout le long et qui
n'ont pu être comblées pour f3 rouge
pour tous et bienvenue un coup dur je
vais peut-être kf5 échec maintenant et
tout reprend 1,5 wef 5 bien joué oui
elle coupe la connexion et regarde là le
truc c'est quand tu joues un coup comme
ça en bullet avec peu de temps tu fait
très mal en réalité cavalière trois
échecs prise caïds et 4 qui revient on
n'attaque le pion à ses trois et ça
c'est hyper pénible à jouer avec les
noirs
j'ai deux partout insiste alors à ils
arrivent à s'en sortir la tête bref deux
atouts elle va gagner la pièce
incroyable valentina qui se fait piéger
comme une débutante tourcoing à 6 france
et 2 allez faut quand même se battre un
petit peu roi b2 faut revenir une fois
vu jouer vite pour elle elle s'invente
pas s'il va en plus tu peu près mou
wallon valentina classe quand même un
qui abandonnent oui c'est pas pour toi
kevin qui joue ton autre chacun chacun
soit 15 ans d'école après du coup le
score ça donne 10 partout il reste 18
ça va jouer ça va jouer a jugé jusqu'au
bout ce speech est féminin ouais mais de
quoi elle aimait la vie quand elle a dit
que le boulet année c'est du lourd elle
avait raison
à la véraison et là je trouve encore une
nouvelle fois qu'elle joue très bien ce
bull est démente et parce que regarde le
pion aux cinq qui empêche qui attaquent
le rock et g4 g5 qui arrive ça fait peur
elles sont peut-être bien juger quatre
quand même je pense non la hauteur de ce
à quoi ça va ça va ça va ça va aller sur
le roi est là encore de nouveau un peu
accéléré la cadence 48 secondes en aviez
elle est bien parti pour l'emporter dans
cette partie et reprendre oui les
devants
alors qu'evian c5 c'est plutôt bien joué
un miroir pour amener le tour ajoute
donc j'ai un maire peut-être un peu fumé
on ne sait pas si elle va peut-être
jouer grand kiss i way mais maintenant
prend un point et on prend soin de notre
dame j'ai ici c'est peut-être moi qui
allais dans mon corps bon ça ait changé
quand même est-ce que ce qu'elle peut
prendre en f2 qui a été trois à peine
mieux
en tout cas ça il ya quand même encore
de l'attak pour les blancs ah oui c'est
ça on dopage défaut des crédits accordés
m6 et là y'a pas tout rejet inquiets
genre très dangereux non non à la
corruption au kenya tout autour des 8
mai et après comment tu développes je
sais pas juste faut pas faire tout
reprend celle qui est des six qui s'est
vite puisqu'il y aura pour ces cinq
échecs à la fin donc et angers 5 c'est
très bête g5 ici seul coup avec le pop
rock est tour g5 du coup j'ai pas
tourner vite c'était peut-être plus oui
on va voir comment ça se développe les
noirs qui montre le roi et touré fuite
peut-être un fou des cinq peut-être je
sais pas c'est un peu chaud je sais pas
qui tu préfères toile et blanc encore
qu'ils n'aiment pas ouais c'est dur à 6
km avec le cavalier c'est plus facile à
jouer et un peu plus plongé toujours un
truc et à la thg 5 qui a plongé celle
qui va tomber
voilà
deux pions bessette qui va tomber aussi
annoncé à 100 à schwyz
ça arrive et ça va faire plus ça c'est
terrible pour valentina c'est terrible
est juste moins forte ce soir et ça fait
plus un pur et l'ina mais ce que
valentina va réussir à retourner la
vapeur et revenir dans ce match
rien n'est moins sûr la petite caro
cannes
il a changé elle a bien joué dans les
premiers matches ck rocade cavaliers 17
f6 menace m'attendais 2 et tout ça c'est
qu'on a une bonne tête pour les blancs
mais bon décidemment c'est pas si pire
[Musique]
ouais c'est vrai que c'est vrai que ça
reste solide pour les noirs j'ai pris
par la main aussi même s'ils sont certes
difficiles comme la française est un
vêtement c'est compliqué bon bah elle va
juste envoyer la taxe sur le roi à nîmes
tours un pion à f4 est attaqué il va
falloir sacrifier quelque part un moment
donné peut-être l hyper sont fous
bessette
enfin vous êtes un jour du cavalier avec
quatre tirs aux draps à voir si aucun ok
pourquoi pas non mais là elle envoie l
envoi est peut-être tour f 3 twh 3 qui
arrive à l'est pour les blancs dans tous
les cas ouais tu veux tu es là tu elle
veut juste attaqué 15.5 donc
est ce que les noirs réussissent à se
défendre plus ou moins ici à la tour c 8
qui a attaqué maintenant c'est plus le
cas de six prisons alors là ça va mais
très dangereux pour le moins le défend
et passiez ton qui est peut-être un peu
près là elle prend du cavalier damage 5j
c'est fou ce mot cette mère prend il la
donne avec la dame en point en ce 7 mai
après 3,7 c'est dur à calculer pourquoi
je sais pas j'avais peur du cavalier a
fait 4 mais n'en sais rien il faut
prendre des points
non mais c'est fini alors c'est fini à
dammaj 5 qui arrive au prochain en mai
au caire alors tu avec ses 3 l ataxie
d'ahmed de m1 et barracuda match 4 aida
match 3 peut-être non à une quinzaine de
ses deux poupées 3 en tout cas elle
s'est un peu fou ou rouge
non mais fois j'attends ce que d'un
premier fils a qualifié trois échecs
elle n'a pas vu et rêve maintenant elle
a peu après chez lui à wemmel peut
monter avec le roi c'est ça tout élément
y a plus rien incroyable est là elle a
raté le ko les acteurs qui avaient
d'autres tactiques qui marchait s'est
pas encore finir il ya peu de temps pour
les noirs ouais mais c'est l'argent l
approche non halal à la dame qui est
tombé en un ça s'est passé sur les
dernières c'est la seconde
la lame qui est tombé incroyable
incroyable égalité de nouveau et ce
partout et vanina qui devrait faire un
café avec système de londres avec le
pion ans et 6 d'indécis c'est ça qu'on
remarque ça existe mais bon tu as peut
être un peu un peu compliqué dont il ya
combien il ya 11 partout 11 minutes à
jouer démente et ça va se jouer dans les
dernières secondes cette histoire cette
finale attention parce que les blancs
peut-être le temps de fermer quatre des
cinq ce qui est une mauvaise nouvelle il
n'y a pas le temps de faire à 6 donc ça
il va falloir réussir à réagir
rapidement avec eux cinq ici sinon tu
vas te prendre tu comprends que l'on
prend fois ci sous bessette est fou
prend ses six donc valence ou revoir
latina qui est déconnecté ouais la
mauvaise position des connexions à onze
minutes de la fin c'est dur assez dur
parce qu'en plus tout à l'heure elle se
reconnecter dans l'est dans les deux
trois secondes qui suivaient là ça fait
trente secondes qu'elle est déconnecté
déjà à y est le match qui pourrait lui
filer entre les doigts
ouais c'est même même même pour la
compétition je trouve que c'est un peu
dommage finir là-dessus en plus haut
bien un moment où ça lui arrive c'est
dans la séquence de cinq plus un ça
aurait été jouable
ryanair est juste on continue aïe aïe
aïe aïe aïe à valentina et en plus là si
elle retrouve pas la connexion dans les
trois minutes ça va continuer à filer
les parties vont continuer ça va pas
s'arrêter
elle doit elle boit une boisson
chocolatée non c'est bien précieux c'est
l'énergie laurentides à tout sourire sur
la photo c'est rare non mais il
s'oriente en général ouais pas quand
elle joue mais serait pas moins
souriante
alors elle classique écrit c'est le jeu
ma pauvre lucette
c'est difficile et elina je donnerai la
suivante toi tu ferais quoi moi je
donnerai pas je dis franchement
ah ben ça ne m'attend pas je commenterai
tout connaître
toi tu rentrer ou pas non mais c'est pas
vrai et puis en fait je me rends compte
de plus en plus que tout les quand tu
joues contre des joueurs forts ils
rentrent jamais en fait oui c'est le
sport c'est d'aider banalité c'est ta
faute
oui plus que le jeu pour les membres et
donc oui non franchement ça me paraît
normal de pas rendre personnellement
après après c'est la vie c'est comme ça
c'est la compétition et sa main tu sais
pas en fait
mais même en russie fin souvent on m'a
dit ça fait genre en russie sur en
france c'est parce qu'on joue un tournoi
et qu'on me disait ah ouais t'as gagné
par forfait genre tu n'as aucune valeur
j'envoie il a gagné par forfait et tout
genre ici on m'a toujours dit ok mais le
premier truc à faire dans une partie
celles à venir s'asseoir en fait donc si
tu viens déjà t'asseoir ben bravo à toi
quoi c'était déjà arrivé j'étais déjà
assis falla le premier truc sur une
profession par internet c'est d'avoir
internet pas ça fait partie du boulot à
faire pour jouer exactement oui c'est
pas la faute de
les vagues d'une connexion non alors
qu'est ce qu'on vient d'entendre des
commandes non mahorais on attend là pour
le moment on ne sait pas je peux je peux
essayer de choper des infos parce que
gégé le je peux me connecter à l'essai
rares à bien est-ce que ça recommence je
crois oui alors ouais ça recommence
mais ça recommence sont calmes mais non
alors ça recommence pas du tout je ne
sais pas ce qu'ils font non non ça
recommence pas attendu et j'ai essayé de
mes 6 ans joue ou c'est pas beaucoup
mais c'est très bizarre ce que sur le
live officielle en fait il suffit plus
le match donc autant je comprends rien
je vais regarder parce que je pense pas
que ce soit une partie qui contraint à
presser le pas un un coin ces polémiques
c'est que j'ai un jour non mais c'est
sûr qu'elles jouent leur parti là ça
c'est sûr mais je pense pas que la
partie compte en fait parce qu'ils sont
plus connectés je pense en fait qu'ils
ont fait un chargeur de time out dans le
match
un genre de père arrive à une pause
parce que ça m'étonnerait ça
m'étonnerait tu vois pas ce qu on fait
tout ce qu'on a derrière la tue à
l'écran derrière c'est le live officiel
donc ça m'étonnerait que le sait la fin
du speech s se joue pendant une page de
pub mais alors que joue alors sept
parkings voir alors elle joue vraiment
la partie si tu veux mais ça comptera
pas je pense non c'est vraiment elle qui
joue mais ça m'étonnerait que ça compte
surtout qu'ils voient que la reconnexion
de valentina n'est pas au mieux bon
écoute c'est de toute façon heureusement
que ça compte pas parce qu elles
reperdaient sur une déconnexion alors je
viens de voir un match de pain que ça va
être compliqué de finir le match
ouais c'est franchement je suis un peu
déçu des ventes est bas moins chier
parce que je n'aimerais pas que justin
bieber
j'ai plus de corps officiels je sais
plus rien et coûte je suis perdu j'ai
plus d'infos écoute en tout cas pour ton
premier match on a quand même vécu
jusqu'ici un des trois premières heures
vingt de match était vraiment vraiment
palpitant intéressant ouais c'était
vraiment intéressant
du coup tu élargi ton vocabulaire petit
à petit ça prend des mois déjà palpitant
tu connaissais comme oh pardon palpitant
non ne connaît pas pas de bis temps ça
veut dire excitant intéressant un
palpitant c'est un peu ce qu'on vient de
voir que c'était un match serré
intéressant pas de bouton j'aime bien la
maj comme ça mais c'était sympa mais bon
c'est ça c'est un mec comme ça c'est
vraiment dommage parce que j'aimerais
bien pouvoir le porter jusqu'aux enfants
par les forfaits weppes et en plus cela
c'était le moment plus intéressant à
trois parties égalité ça ça a joué gros
quoi oui on va demander à mathieu pour
la suite il ya un vocabulaire plus
fournie quand ils te parle pour
t'apprendre des mots tu arrivé dans le
chatt faut faire le boulot mathieu mais
vous parle en français ou en anglais
avec mathieu ancien maintenant voilà au
début j'ai parlé à l'anglais mais après
j'ai beaucoup travaillé mon français
avec un livre tout seul et
j'ai des plans des scènes ont maintenant
passé par bien principe est ce que tu
lis en français des livreurs
j'ai lu récemment de livres 1 français
mais en général je préfère de lure
indiqué mannion lorsque pour moi lire un
livre c'est pour se détendre et quand je
les enlève étrangères ça ne me tente pas
complètement parce que si je connais pas
les mots je voulais décrié moi ce que je
vais bien je comprends après c'est vrai
d'abord je pense pas que la parra si la
partie compte et le score c'est bien
13-11 donc la dernière partie qu'elles
ont joué là pendant la pub elle comptait
vraiment ils ont fait compter et donc
l'accord et de 13,11 il ya deux points
d'écart à la pause ralink - ouais là on
voit sur son visage la pauvre elle est
vraiment maintenant elle est dépitée
allez on va on va espérer qu'elle puisse
gagner ça là au moins histoire de garder
un peu de suspense dans ce match aller
on se porte
ouais on espère au moins un peu de un
peu de suspense mais la position qui est
assez égal pour le moment attention aux
pions des cinq halls un conte -
peut-être pour cent comme on était cinq
croit que dame prend des 5 au 6 mai le
fouette un prix sur 24 alors là el
alaoui et surtout qu'il prend le cet
échec
l'intermédiaire ajoute au père noël et
ses soutiens à oui ça je n'ai pas vu à
c'est très bien joué alors là j'ai
l'impression
ouais pas prendre le fou ses impressions
que dans les têtes des quatre ici peut
être un problème dans ce cas peut être
une idée des nombreux tout comme alex
kovalev processus g bâle on n'a pas su
je pense je pense qu'il y avait eu y
avait peut-être quelque chose on a
raconté n'importe quoi démonter mais on
a un peu comme valentina on a un peu
abasourdi
on est un peu dans le dur il ya trois
points d'écart valentina qui est
désespérée à l'écran ça va se terminer
là dessus démente et 6 minutes 40 de jeu
trois parties y aura pas le temps
ouais je te sens je te sens très déçu
aussi
oui je suis très ce vraiment c'est pas
très intéressant ouais c'est dommage
après comme on l'a dit c'est ça fait
partie du jeu c'était aussi à valentina
de d'avoir une connexion descente mais
il faut prendre un marché mathieu
cornette qui nous confirme je vous
promets de marché vous prendrez un
marché son ami eric m6 mais c'est vrai
que valentina c'est incroyable la
différence de visages quoi c'est
incroyable elle qui a toujours la même
expression là tu vois vraiment qu'elle
et elle a l'air tellement triste et
désespéré c'est fou c'est incroyable
alors cette partie et ce qu'elle peut
ouais bah là en tout cas elle va
attaquer quoi on put à tout principe de
l emprunt c'est peut-être tu pouvais
changer les tours est attaqué à main le
roi a dit laissez vous qu'en valais
m'évite de tête h4 maintenant h4 au
minium aller non
ben un peu timorée elle joue un petit
peu petit bras
elle joue un peu de manière trop
sécurisées ouais elle va plus attaquer
je crois qu'il y ait plus dans la tête
oui 3 non c'est marche ou pas pour
l'instant car j'en sais si c'est bien
joué car elle est à 5 sec et revient
elle peut peut-être mettre le carillon
des huit ans
libérez la dame décision et maintenant
d'un des trois bêtes est assez bien joué
à la place
qari yousef pourrait prendre
c'est simple d'oeuvre ne pense pas aux
autres
c'est parti à leur tour c'est difficile
la tour qui avance et vite le cavalier
qui est cloué chez qui revient vers le 7
et f4 ouais mais elle revêt elle fait
des allers-retours avec le cas mais je
pense qu'elle n'a pas trop de plans non
plus mais elle joue vite et ça ça suffit
pas faire son bonheur et à son tour
prend ces deux peut-être un ferme et
directeur français et je peux prendre un
tram on est peut-être ça marche et on ne
sait pas
donc ouais inaki pyatt ont elles fait
enlever cette dame 17 elle connaît bien
les règles du ces pour l heure même si
elle fait durer la partie 20 30 coût de
plus c'est déjà bien alain bessette
voilà il ya toujours le dilemme est ce
que tu la joues jusqu'au bout avec les
noirs pour faire tourner le chrono c'est
ce qu'avait fait gris tchouk contre
maxime vachier lagrave alors pichon il
ya des fous en c1 qui en prit ce qui est
des cahiers des quatre tours français
qui a valu aux deux d'ailleurs qu'elle a
raté mais bon si vite mais peut-être
ouais là ça commence à être dur pour
pourri li na waie tué pour le 5ème elle
va jouer elle va jouer le plus longtemps
possible
il ya quand même un titre en jeu et d'un
8 mat
il reste maintenant à l'esi à l'égal ou
diminuer les 30 loin mais si elle gagne
avant la fin des deux minutes de la
minute trente ça ça ça ira
parce que sa relance une partie en fait
alors qu'on a perdu des montées
on a retrouvé des montées à taper on a
retrouvé on a perdu monte à retrouver
pas de soucis tu vois à l'écran
y'a pas de problème oui oui c'est donc
la situation est simple démentez il faut
gagner dans les deux minutes qui restent
pour pour valentina afin de pouvoir
lancer une dernière partie afin de
revenir mais ne risque pas si ses
qualités
alors on joue un match en bullet de
quatre parties d'accord
en cas d'égalité mais si si et lina joue
comme moi et qu'elle décide de faire
tourner la pendule tu vois elle peut
déjà faire tourner et 50 secondes en
attendant donc c'est très difficile de
gagner en deux minutes si ton adversaire
est pas s'appeler est normalement quand
il ya un titre en jeu il n'y a pas de
raison de l'être
c'est vraiment une question de fair-play
c'est la règle donc
vu que séduire un plus un ça semble
quand même très compliqué mais bon tout
est encore possible
il faut absolument que valentina attaque
et aïe aïe aïe chercher un math rapide
en tout cas une position une position d'
attaque mais là c'est pas c'est pas trop
le cas dans la position assez égal il ya
beaucoup de pièces qui s'échangent je
jouais dit tenté un piège mais la prime
c'est que c'est je crois que ça marchait
mais bon ni de jouer cette année c'est
un peu un peu dans le dur
un peu fatigué mais tu sais elin à elle
connaît la règle elle sait comment ça se
passe
à mon avis elle se dit juste la position
et secure je fais tourner tu voi elle va
encore échanger nos classes où elle n'a
pas besoin de compléter la chose je
t'aime et voudrait changer
ab3 mais bon ça va repousser trois
encore et tour des 4 mai rivard b5 et
non mais tu vas jamais gagné ça non et
surtout ça va te prendre très longtemps
à gagner quand bien même tu gagnerais
d'un coup bas mais on tend encore 35 le
temps de un nom en plus il reste combien
de temps il ya un an il reste plus de
tant de façons c'est fini c'est gagner
des ventes et quoi qu'il se passe quoi
qu'il se passe et la dernière partie
c'est la dernière partie qu'on est en
train de vivre et il reste il reste plus
de temps et lina qui va chercher là nul
et voilà ça se terminera là dessus et tu
vas voir le visage de valentine à kankan
le match va s'arrêter tu vois c'est
toujours vrai on a un petit décalage
donc on va s'en rendre compte
est-ce que s'il ya une explosion de joie
ou pas non valentina qui est curé est il
inquiet pas pas spécialement qu'on a si
regarde ce qu'ils peuvent
ballet heureuse à la gagner le match a
expliqué elle est vraiment heureux de
regarde
bon bah écoute ça se finit là dessus est
né ce patient à elena qui c'est bien
monsieur comment comment on peut
conclure ça est ce que finalement sur
quoi ça s'est joué d'après toi son coin
du film when le match sur quoi hisser
sur quoi il sait jouer je ne sais pas la
connexion tu penses au final quand je ne
sais pas mais au début par la dina a
arrêté quelques possibilités pour gagner
je te rappelle les meilleures parties
ouais et après mais elles il y avait 1 4
point décors des corps de quatre points
non wen est à +4 exactement mais elle l
aimait s'est très bien battu pour un
réveillon c'est pas possible de la
manière d'un réussi un coup ça non et
c'est bien mathieu les revenus et wave
allant de valentina qui a un peu craqué
et puis après il ya tout s'est enchaîné
je trouve que des fois elle a joué juste
trop vite et trop peu cependant si elle
faisait des coups comme au caire sans
infléchir d'année un plan où j'ai caché
s'acquitter en russie well as fait elle
a fait des blagues à fait à la fedecam
écouter en tout cas c'était un grand
plaisir de commenter avec toi pour une
première je trouve que tu as été super
donc mais franchement c'était super pas
très bien très bien réagit bien parler
français et était bien dans le rythme
franchement je tenais je tenais je te
valide je te certifie je tenais en tant
que seul un temps bien certifié et
j'espère que c'est une première mais pas
une dernière je suis heureux très ferme
voire couple cette expérience était
intéressant d'avoir des matches on va en
avoir en avoir on avoir donc l'occasion
et j'espère qu'on va peut-être l'année
prochaine donc je commande pas avec toi
mais que je compte ton match mais si
l'on écoute on espère mais serge
glissera un mot à daniel reyne choix
très intéressant merci à toi pas se
passer tous une bonne une excellente
soirée bonne soirée à toi des faits
aussi tiens j'en vois un petit raid 1-2
c'est un truc de switcher en fait on a
envoyé tous nos toute personne on va les
envoyer sur le stream officiel pour
qu'ils suivent l'interview